But you've got to fake mail now.
You son of a bitch,
it's supposed to be me out me out by the
way is welded into the desk of the new
studio desk,
the uh,
the foot of the dead,
the legs of the desk.
I had it made constructive by an artist.
Our friend Eric,
he did a sick job on it and one of the
things that he did just on his own is
write the word me out on the side.
Cause this silly bitch says meow
at the beginning of every podcast.
You got to appreciate the little things
in life studies and John and Brian
brings the bizarre little things.
Just this,
the extra flavor.
It's a salt on the meat.
You know what I'm saying,
son,
we will be in Minneapolis this weekend.
I think there's a couple of tickets left,
but it was,
it was basically almost sold out.
Um,
and that is at the pantageous theater.
It will be Joey motherfucking,
Coco Diaz,
Brian Red band.
And Doug Benson is also going
to stop in and do a set.
That shit be crazy.
Yo.
That's an awesome.
So yeah,
we're going to have some fun.
We're going to have some
fun and Minneapolis is
awesome and it hasn't frozen
over yet,
so we're going to get to him
right before shit freezes.
Get in,
get out.
Boom.
We also have a show this
Wednesday night at the Ice House,
a 10:00 PM show.
We're going to do these
on a regular basis.
I'm not doing it next week because
I'm going hunting like a man.
Brian Callen,
Steve Rinella and I are
going to go deer hunting.
I'm going to earn my meat bitches or not,
or become a Vegan free counts bitch.
It's very possible psychedelics,
while you're out there
listening,
Jesus son,
Jesus.
But uh,
this Wednesday night it
will be a Greg Fitzsimmons,
uh,
Ian Edwards,
I think.
No,
Doug Benson can't do it.
Hans and I saw both of those
guys at the La Pod fest.
Greg with hilarious.
Greg is always hilarious.
He's great comic.
Greg and I have been friends
for fucking 23 years.
That's when we started
doing stand up together.
He's a,
he's old school dude.
Funny as fuck though.
He slayed that audience.
Yeah,
he's a fucking professional.
Um,
uh,
I think,
oh Dunkin Dunkins doing it to too.
Okay.
So,
hey everybody.
So this Wednesday night at the ice house,
it's Ian Dunk,
Ian Edwards.
Fucking hilarious dude.
Duncan Trussell of course.
Hilarious.
Brian Redman,
you know him,
she loves him and uh,
uh,
Greg motherfucking Fitzsimmons so
we're going to have a good time.
That's 10 o'clock.
It's 15 bucks and a we do
on a regular basis here.
We were asked recently to
start doing everyone's day.
So it's as much as a of that as I can.
Sometimes I'm going to be on the road,
but uh,
when I'm,
when I'm in town we're going to try
to do it and just a cool place for our
friends to go and do stand up.
And uh,
the guys that you'll see are all going
to be really funny guys cause uh,
we don't hang out with my scrubs.
Yo.
You know what I'm saying?
I think my fucking flap
talk really quietly.
The Joe Rogan Experience,
oh,
hi primate.
My higher primary t shirts are into,
if you go to higher-primate.com
people have been asked.
I finally got all that shit taken care of.
Look,
I'm a fucking terrible businessman,
ladies,
and shut up my only about it,
but I got some dope tee shirts.
I supposed to do my taxes today.
Whoops.
Whoops,
though you're a terrible
business person too.
I'm horrible.
I was like,
Hey,
I'll just take the whatever the,
the,
you get fined or something like money.
Right.
It's not like you go
to prison immediately,
right?
No.
I think you get to pay it,
but you get fine.
Yeah.
Just do that.
The
type of brain that you know
is like really organized.
That's not the type of person
that does a silly podcast.
It's a totally different type of brain.
I'm convinced of that.
You know,
I fight with my,
uh,
illogical tendencies and
my procrastination in,
in,
in pulse liveness and craziness.
But I think that's the only way comedians,
brains work,
I don't think.
Yeah.
I think it's just a constant
struggle to try to mend it.
The society with that fucking
whacked down noodle on your head,
Bryan red band.
Anyway,
higher-primary.com.
That's the tee shirt company.
It's all like monkeys and
mushrooms and shit and,
and there's a really cool Joey d
shirt and they're very soft shirts.
High Quality.
Sure.
Regular like fucking normal shirts.
It's like the highest quality we can get.
We got really high
quality soft tee shirts,
so it's like a fashion tee shirt,
you know,
that was the options.
The options were spent a lot of money
on really expensive tee shirts or sell
cheap ones.
But I think they'd come out cool this way.
It's,
they're expensive,
they're not cheap,
but they're really well made.
So that's what it is on [inaudible]
dot coms or other sponsor.
Uh,
if you go to o n n it and use a code name,
Rogan,
you will save 10% off
any of the supplements.
The explanations for all these
supplements are all also at on it.
I do a terrible job
explaining these things.
Perhaps Dave Asprey could help us
because he's far smarter than I and these
things.
Um,
but I don't really know what's going on.
I just don't want to use it.
It's awesome.
And there's a bunch of studies that
say the stuff inside of it is awesome.
A Alpha brain is my favorite
supplement period I had.
So one thing that I make sure
I don't go anywhere without,
if I'm doing a podcast
to bring it with me,
I'm doing a comedy show,
I bring it with me.
I take it before every UFC.
Uh,
it's not going to turn a genius
or a moron into a genius,
but I really definitely feel
like it gives me a mental boost,
if that makes any sense.
And there's been shut studies have shown
that the ingredients in the doses that
we use it have had positive
effects and studies.
So we're,
we're doing our own studies right now.
It takes 10 to 12 months for
a double blind placebo study,
uh,
from this university in Boston.
And when they're done,
they take it and the,
you know,
process all the information and
figuring out whether or not it's legit.
So we'll,
we'll have actual studies,
but the ingredients that are in
the study or the ingredients,
whether they're in Alpha brain,
in the doses that we use,
have shown positive results.
It just,
no one's ever proven that there's a
synergistic effect of all the ingredients
together.
That's the controversial aspect of it.
Here's the deal though,
the way we have it set up at on it,
you get 100% money back
from the first 30 pills.
If you don't think it works,
if it's not your thing,
everybody's body's different.
I don't know what you feel,
and I know some people can't drink.
I know some people can't smoke pot.
Some people can't eat.
The bodies are different.
If it's not,
if you don't feel it,
I'm going to what your sensitivity is.
If you don't think it's worth it,
you get a hundred percent money back.
You don't have to return the product.
Nobody's trying to rip you off.
We're trying to sell you
shit that I use everything.
We sell it on it,
whether it's vitamins or the BLENDTEC
blenders that are coming in tomorrow.
We start selling house
because Kale shakes pitches.
You got to get your morning
started off correct.
I'm telling you the way to live life,
it's,
it's a healthier way to get out of bed.
That's my newest phrase,
by the way.
I say that all to Kale,
shake pitches.
Kale shakes his fucking guy
in the underground side.
I went to the supermarket
and there was no Kale.
Damn you,
Joe Rogan.
I noticed like restaurants.
I'll have like Kale,
everything like Kale,
Caesar Salads now Kale.
Yeah.
When we were in Phoenix,
I had a Kale Caesar Salad.
Yeah.
I think Kale is becoming more popular now.
It's just one of the people.
It's a super food.
I mean people are realizing how it's,
it's really,
it's got a lot of protein in [inaudible].
Crazy.
Good for you.
It's really fucking good for you and
when you have it in this massive dose.
The way I do it,
I take the,
the,
the recipes available at
[inaudible] Dot com my recipe,
my recipe is pretty extreme.
It's got a lot of garlic in it.
It's got a lot of ginger in it,
and it's got a fucking wall up plug.
It hits you.
It's,
it's intense,
but Ooh,
you feel good afterwards.
God Damn,
everything just feels
it's alive.
Um,
anyway,
we also sell kettle bells,
battle ropes.
Like I said,
we have the BLENDTEC blenders
coming in and the supplements,
there's new mood,
which is a great five HTP and l tryptofan
supplement that it enhances your,
your brain's production of Serotonin and
l Tryptofan converts into five HTP and
five HTP converts into Serotonin,
right?
So I correct.
Yep.
Yeah.
And this is all done.
Here's all the scientific
studies behind all this stuff.
And all the information available
is not just an audit.com,
but at Google,
if you Google nootropics,
you'll get a better idea of whether
or not you're interested in anything.
Um,
the most important thing to worry to,
to,
uh,
to have on mine.
Those,
you don't have to worry about it.
So they're just new trans,
it's not drugs.
You're not going to test
positive for anything at work,
including the hemp force protein.
That's a big question that
comes up all the time.
If you have the hemp force protein,
no you will.
There's no way you can taste positive
or rather test positive for marijuana.
Hemp is completely non psychoactive.
It's just a protein.
It's just plants.
It's just,
it's not.
It's like a cousin to
pot and it's illegal.
Unfortunately.
You can grow it,
you can buy it and you can sell it,
but you can't grow it,
which is a fucking crazy.
It just shows you what a silly,
silly,
silly government we have
cause it's an awesome plan.
It's got all the amino acids
in it you can make fuel out of.
At Henry Ford made one of his
first cars out of it and the,
the fiber of the hemp plant is so durable.
It's really like an alien planet.
The fact that we don't use it,
just the hemp part,
forget about the pot smoking pot.
Forget about all that.
Completely pretend that pot didn't exist.
It was never invented.
No one ever had it.
The hemp itself,
making something like hemp illegal is
one of the dumbest things a human being
can do.
It's almost like making apples illegal.
It's worse than making apples illegal
because you can't make a house out of
apples.
They make a fucking house at a hemp.
You can construct cars out of
it that are stronger than steel.
It's insane how strong the
fibers of this shit is.
It makes a far superior paper.
It makes far superior clothing.
Things that don't rip,
but the reason why it's illegal is because
way back in the 1930s they invented a
machine called the decorticator and that
decorticator takes hemp fiber and it
breaks it down and it turns it
into something that's useful.
It's a long and lengthy process that
they used to use slaves for though in
slavery became illegal.
It's much easier to get cotton and
use cotton than it is to use hemp,
so that's why it's illegal.
They all conspired,
all these people that didn't want to lose
out to the hemp industry in the cotton
industry,
in the paper industry,
especially William Randolph Hearst,
he ran newspapers and he printed stories
about Mexican smoking marijuana and
raping white women.
It was all like just craziness to get
this one plant illegal and it was actually
for its use as a commodity.
That's what they were trying to
squash had nothing to do with it being
psychoactive.
It's amazing that that it,
that hustle has lasted so long.
Anyway,
we have hemp protein that we buy from
Canada and it's the shit it's called hemp
force.
What are you doing?
You're doing like,
exactly.
That's what I'm saying.
I can't handle the truth either.
I can't heal the truth cause even
when I say it when I say that,
like that store that I just told,
I know that to be a fact
of reddit everywhere.
It sounds so dumb.
It sounds so ridiculous.
It makes me angry.
It's like people are,
people are just beyond stupid.
Brian.
Yes.
Anyway,
enough of me.
Go to ana.com that's o.
N.
I.
T.
Oh,
I almost forgot the tangle that
got a lot of fucking commercials,
man.
If I was on an internet,
I would be complaining about me right now.
A lot of commercials.
You just always go really
long on the Onnit one.
Well,
you know,
here's the thing.
I go along on anything that I absolutely
believe in it because you're on it.
I am on it and it also is because I would,
I do in the middle.
I don't know how everybody
else is doing them,
but I think a lot of people are
sticking them in the conversations now.
I know that that's what Adam Carolla does.
He does like podcasts and then he does
commercial is like a radio show that I
think that fucks with me.
Maybe that's why the flashlight was
pretty fun because I can always bring the
flat side.
It's like the olive garden.
Yes.
You always could.
I don't think we should keep it
as a sponsor just for that reason.
Ting is an excellent product though
and everything we sell on his podcast,
I guess we're selling things.
Everything we promote,
there we go.
Everything we're paid to promote is,
is things that we believe in 100%.
Um,
you don't ever have to worry
about us trying to rip you off.
If there's anything that's being
talked about on this podcast,
it's always going to be 100%
to the best of my knowledge.
And if I'm ever incorrect,
I will definitely know that I fucked
up and everything that we're selling,
whether it's through on it or
through audible.com or even ting is,
what are you doing with the team
that's not the same pin pong?
What is Ting?
Ting is a cell phone service that you,
you sign up for and they use sprints,
backbone and they sell cool phones.
Like android phones.
Like the galaxy s three
is big fucking cool.
Last one that you see in the
commercials every day lately.
And um,
they have it set up so that
you can quit it anytime you,
you don't have to have contracts.
Your minutes can pile on to
like more than one phone.
Like you can share minutes with like,
you know,
your wife.
Um,
and you also,
if you don't use a certain
amount of minutes every month,
if you're allotted a certain amount
of minutes and you don't use them,
you're dropped dropdown and credited
to the lower level of a payment plan.
So they actually give you money back.
I mean it's a really,
it's a really,
it's like,
it's a really fair company.
It's like I love the,
the,
the ethical way in which they're
choosing to do business there.
They're saying,
we make plenty of money.
Let's just do this really fair.
Let's sell people a quality product.
Like all these killer,
uh,
android phones,
they have regular phones too.
If you're into flip phones.
But what they decided to do is
use this big company's network,
use sprints,
backbone,
which is a huge,
then we can't come up with your own,
but then,
you know,
use it in a way that they feel is fair.
And so they provide an excellent service
and they give you cool phones and you
can quit at any time.
I mean,
there's no contracts.
It's,
it's a really,
it's a beautiful situation and that's
really what I think it should be with
every cell phone company.
It's crazy that you get locked into
these contracts and they rope you in by
giving you some crazy discount on
his phone and it suits all bananas.
But the bottom line is if you
want to leave cause your service,
your service sucks.
It costs a lot of money.
Well,
not with Tang Tang,
you just,
you just bail.
That's it.
Go to rogan.ting.com and you'll save 50
bucks off your first digital cellular
device for talking to people through
the air and you took it beyond Ting.
All right pitches,
Dave Asprey's here.
We're going to get to
the bottom of things.
We're going to get an educated,
we're going to get experienced who?
That's my new,
that's my new tagline
of being in a very show.
It's just cheesy as it gets.
We're going to get some experience
trying by day Joe Rogan podcast by night.
Dude,
we're getting experienced.
We just got out of it from being on it
and now we're getting it back in it.
We're experienced.
Dude.
That's how I'm feeling that right now.
Dave,
thanks for coming man.
Really appreciate it.
Tait Fletcher is your number one
fan.
Boy.
So please give a big shout out
at the beginning of this podcast.
Tate,
you rock man.
Date as bulletproof,
everything.
Every fucking tweety
sends stay bulletproof.
My friends,
it's like he's like the most
interesting man in the world,
but it's about bulletproof.
You know,
instead of stay thirsty,
he totally rocks.
He loves you man.
He's got a fucking serious
man crush on your ideas.
Homeboy came in with a jug.
I love pate.
Me and Tate both have
the coffee addiction.
I love him for a bunch of reasons,
but that's one of them.
We both have the coffee addiction and
take comes in with this fucking ridiculous
like camping for a month mug filled with
bulletproof coffee and he poured bees
up.
It was pretty bad ass man.
That was the first,
uh,
my first experience
with bulletproof coffee.
And this is your creation.
Yup.
And for folks who don't understand
what bulletproof coffee is,
what it consists of,
what's a,
what's in exactly.
It's low toxin coffee,
which has a different mental
effect to than the normal stuff.
This will,
you can just buy on any street corner.
You blend it with grass fed butter
that has certain fatty acids,
short chain fatty acids.
Your brain needs for anti-inflammatory
purposes and you blend it with either
coconut oil or MCT oil,
which is an extract of coconut oil that
six times stronger and you blend it.
It gets foamy and froth.
He just liked the best latte you ever had.
It doesn't taste gross.
It doesn't taste buttery,
oily,
and when you drink it you are full for
eight hours and you have this incredible
focus.
This mental focus,
it's,
it's just insane.
Whoa.
How's that possible?
What is it doing?
It's just,
it's,
it's causing,
it's like a synergistic effect with
the butter and the oil and the coffee.
It makes the stimulant last longer.
Is that what it is?
Well,
the hunger part happens because your body
is getting the short and medium chain
fatty acids that are really
hard to get in your diet,
so because you're doing that,
you're already getting a big boost there
and then we believe that it probably
helps to escort the terpenes
that are inside coffee,
like caffeine,
strong cow hall,
that the psychoactive compounds
that are not caffeine.
We think it helps those go into the brain.
And the other reason that I'm theorizing
that it gives you this kind of boost is
because of the small drops of fat that
are formed when you blend it or called
Micelles and they absorbed better into
the body and your body can burn MCT for
energy without any digestive
process required at all.
This is the thing that like bodybuilders
used to get lean and ripped when
they're in the shedding phase.
It also happens to cure Alzheimer's
disease and it makes you feel really good.
I put it in my Kale shakes.
I put four big teaspoons tablespoons
of coconut oil and it tastes good.
Yeah,
so we've got a good taste to it.
Everyone should be eating coconut oil
unless they're allergic to coconut.
It's that straight forward.
Do you remember when they were saying
the coconut oil is bad for you?
When we were kids,
just like the American soil
association got one in there.
Is that what it was?
Yeah,
they did a like a six week
study of hydrogenated coconut
oil versus their crappy
oil and then what do you know?
It raise cholesterol and til this day
you ask the average like 40 50 year old
American.
You say coconut oil,
they say cholesterol and you're like,
there's not in there.
I'm like,
it's cholesterol free.
Not that it's a problem.
It has cholesterol but salt.
That's another one.
People are so silly.
Salt.
Salt gives you a high blood pressure.
No.
Salt is a fucking mineral.
You dummies.
It's as an essential mineral and
you can have too little of it.
Saul is not making you fat.
That is so crazy that that thought that
salt is making you fat has always driven
me fucking bananas.
It's going to give you high blood
pressure with all that salt.
Do you know that?
That that it raises your blood pressure
within the error margin of a blood
pressure cuff.
That's it.
But it's meaningless.
And why does everybody connect salt,
the high blood pressure it has to
do with the marketing of an anti uh,
blood pressure drugs.
So they found out back in
about 1960 that that was how,
uh,
that,
that was a way to lower blood pressure.
Well,
if you get people to
basically pay more water out,
their blood gets thicker so then
their blood pressure goes down.
So they started looking at salts effect
on that and they went down this path and
get this in 1997,
the Lancet medical journal,
which is kind of a bad ass one,
they published a whole thing about
how the salt myth didn't work,
how there was scientific fraud,
how people probably should have gone
to jail for spending taxpayer money and
making up data.
And yet to this day,
you still hear government campaigns
to lower salt consumption,
knowing full well that it makes your
adrenals break when you don't get enough
salt.
I do 10 grams a day.
I have for 10 years.
I carry a vial of it around with me.
I wouldn't think of starting in the
morning without a teaspoon of salt.
Whoa.
Every morning in your shakes.
Yeah,
there's a reason for it.
Okay.
What kind of salt?
What's the best?
I like the Himalayan crystal salt.
It's still just cause it
comes from the Himalayas
as his dope,
bringing back some fucking
Himalayan salt son,
you know,
and there's other kinds of,
any kind of sea salt is going to do it,
but there's less pollution
in the Himalayan stuff.
And I like the idea that it's aren't
that it's mind to buy one arm to monks.
It's just,
is it really,
you know,
grass fed.
So imagine the only way to get a job,
there's,
you know,
chop off one of your
arms dues would do it.
There's enough people out
there that would do it.
Probably were fucking crazy,
man.
I guarantee you they would do it.
So what is the benefit of putting
the salt in your body every morning?
Here's what happens when
you wake up in the morning,
when you first wake up,
your body says,
and this is like your reptilian brain,
the low level parts of
your operating system,
you don't pay any attention to,
oh,
I mean the whole thing.
Exactly.
So you wake up and it says,
hmm,
this,
this body is going to
stand up in a minute.
And when it stands up,
I've got to have enough blood pressure
in the brain if I don't have enough blood
pressure in the brain and he's going to
pass out in a tiger going to eat him.
So this is like a survival level
imperative inside your body.
So what does it do?
It goes to your adrenal glands and says,
hey buddy,
could you crank up some cortisol and
could you change the sodium to potassium
ratio?
I need you to find sodium,
which is hard for people to do.
That's why we used to pay our
soldiers in salt instead of in gold.
And then it says crank down and
potassium crank up on sodium.
If in the morning you take
your sodium and you drink it,
soon after you wake up,
your adrenal glands don't
have to do all that work.
So then you have that adrenal function
for the rest of the day to feel good.
All
right,
I'll do it.
Or you pulled it out.
Yeah.
Can you put it back up
Tony?
How,
what,
what's happening here folks,
your uh,
your adrenal glands are more relaxed.
I actually recommend this,
especially for women when they're
pregnant because they have enough stress
already.
I have a book coming out in January
about like how to have better genes and
bigger brains in your kid's starting
even before you get pregnant.
The knowingness,
having this knowledge in your head,
does it infuriate you when
you see these lower salt,
you know,
campaigns and you hear
people talking about it,
like,
you know,
lower a low salt foods.
Like what?
What is that?
It used to infuriate me,
but to be honest,
I've done enough of the
meditation and the brain hacking.
Like I don't get mad at
stuff like that cause it,
it's not worth the cost of getting mad.
But what I do is I do something about it.
Like that's why I started
the bulletproof exact blog.
It's that there's a lot of this knowledge.
I used to weigh 300 pounds.
I was profoundly unhealthy for the first
half of my life and no one taught me
any of the things that my body can do.
It's just the knowledge wasn't
out there and now it is,
but there's a credibility
problems and I'm like,
look,
I'm a pretty successful guy and I wouldn't
have been this successful if I hadn't
learned all this stuff.
So here it is and it's free.
I just give it to people.
I've got seven people working
for me now doing this.
Wow.
So you were 300 pounds and how old
were you when this was going on?
See,
I hit a 23 years old.
I hit 300 pounds to 97 hours.
Yeah.
Holy Shit.
That's big.
What was that like?
I mean,
it sucked.
I was fat as a teenager to horrible diet.
Well,
I thought I was eating the right stuff.
You know,
I,
in fact during that time I worked out
six days a week for an hour and a half a
day and I ate 1800 calories.
You know what?
If your hormones are Jack,
you're not going to lose weight.
I did eat less than my thin friends.
I just couldn't lose the weight.
I was tired all the time too.
And you have thyroid,
anything with your thought?
I did have some thyroid issues,
but it wasn't just thyroid.
Like there's all kinds of toxin and even
like swelling that happens in the body.
If you have chronic
inflammation turned on,
you're going to be storing
a third of your fat.
Maybe it's not even fat,
it's just like tissue inflammation.
So for me,
I had to figure out what was causing my
inflammation and what's your cortisol
level?
So there's all these delicate hormones
that you manipulate through your food and
through your environment and
the idea that calories in,
calories out matters.
I tell you,
I ran this experiment.
It was a little crazy.
I know that the calorie
thing is completely broken
because we're not robots.
You know,
we're not like a car.
You put gas in and you get so many miles.
As long as the wind
resistance is the same.
So I thought I would eat
4,000 calories a day.
I'd sleep five hours a night or less and
I'd stop exercising and I thought maybe
I'll gain,
you know,
a couple pounds in a
month or two and I'll say,
look,
I should have gained 10 pounds.
I gained two pounds.
I went for two years.
I posted a picture of a six
pack that grew during that time.
I should have weighed 616 pounds
after two years of this program.
I'm not counting the sleep deficit
and I weighed two 10 at the end of it.
And actually it was more
muscular than I was before.
Of course,
I was drinking bulletproof coffee,
I was doing bulletproof
intermittent fasting,
which I developed during that time,
which is intermittent fasting.
But you have only fat in the morning,
which gives you this huge boost,
the one that Tate was talking
about when he was here with you.
So can do all these crazy
things with the body.
But I'll,
I'll tell you a fight out like fat doesn't
make you fat and calories don't make
your fat calories fuel your
brain though they're useful,
but they're not a very good way
of measuring your intake of food.
So what is it?
What?
How does someone get fat?
Then it turns out things
like Leptin resistance,
things like inflammation in the gut
and things like insulin all play a role
there.
What happens is your mitochondria
and your cells also can get weak.
You actually get used to having eat
every two hours is this idea of frequent
snacking to keep your energy up.
What you're doing is you're teaching
the body to actually like need to not be
able to store,
to not be resilient.
It's not be able to store
any kind of calories at all.
What I do is I teach my body to burn fat
and I keep my calories at at least 50%
of my calories are coming from fat.
And most of that is saturated fat
with some Omega threes mixed in.
And what happens there is I can eat
pretty much as much as I can stand and I
won't gain any weight that way.
So it's,
it's simply what causes
obesity isn't one single thing.
But I will tell you one of the unknown
things that is a major contributor is
synthetic estrogen in the environment.
A lot of that comes from
mold in our food supply.
It's called Zarrella known.
We actually purify it and
feed it to industrial beef.
We put it in a little waxy
pellet in the cow's ear.
And here's an example of how much this
stuff works you use around unknown.
It can increase what they call feed
efficiency for livestock by 30% feed
efficiency means if I don't give them
this drug and I give him a pound of food,
they gain,
you know,
however many ounces of fat or or
meat that the cow is going to gain.
You put this pellet in their area
changed or hormonal function,
they gain 30% more weight
on the same amount of food.
That stuff is fat soluble
and it bioaccumulates.
You do not want to be eating hormone
treated beef that was treated to get fat
really,
really quickly.
So we know flat out just
because in animal husbandry,
if we can change the calories in,
calories out equation by 30% why couldn't
we do in humans and the answer as we
can and that's why every
time someone tells me,
measure how much you eat and measure
how much you exercise and you'll lose
weight.
It's the biggest myth.
I have the whole a
whole big like research,
like 30 references,
a blog post about that.
It's just not true.
It never was.
So when someone drops their calories
down and exercises and starts losing fat,
what,
what are they doing?
You can do it for a little
while but here's what happens
and I can tell you this
cause I did that lots of times
you lose 25 pounds again,
25 pounds to lose 25 pounds.
So it's a slingshot sort of a thing and
there's something called epigenetics and
epigenetics is like one of
the main subject of this
book that I wrote and it's,
it's awesome because epigenetic shows how
the environment changes the expression
of your genes and you get signals from
the environment all the time and two of
the biggest signals that you can ever
send your body that changed the way you
actually methalate your DNA are,
there's a threat,
there's something chasing
me and it won't stop.
And you do this by going for a run
every single day without rest instead of
practicing high intensity
interval training or instead
of giving yourself some
recovery time.
There's a lot of athletes and even non
athletes who are just playing overtrained
they don't get enough recovery time to
actually build the muscle up that they
should build cause they had to go rip
it down again by lifting the next day.
Right.
So that's one signal,
which is that like there's a threat to
my species because I keep getting injured
on a daily basis.
I keep having to run.
The other signal you can send is there's
a famine and you tell your body there's
a famine by eating low
calories or low fat diets.
When you do that,
it changes your gene expression.
And we know that people who went through
a famine that their grandkids have a
two to three times higher chance
of getting type two diabetes.
This stuff passes down
through the generations.
So I'll tell you flat out,
like if you're going on,
especially a low fat Vegan Diet
and you're planning to reproduce,
your kids are going to be weaker
than they would have been before.
And the evidence there
is pretty darn strong.
It's a multiple generation of fact.
Wow.
So a Vegan diet is lacking.
And what it's lacking in saturated fat.
For one thing,
a way to make up for it
in with a Vegan Diet,
if you're conscious about it,
you can get some in coconut oil,
but coconut oil does not have
conjugated linoleic acid.
It doesn't have a lot of
the micronutrients that are
present in animal products.
You can probably get by on a vegetarian,
a very careful vegetarian by it,
but diet,
but in terms of being like fully optimal
as in kicking ass at the maximum level
of what the human body can do,
it's going to take more
than just egg yolks.
It's going to take some steak and it's
going to take some lamb and it's going to
take some cod liver oil
and things like that.
If you're going to be 100% Vegan.
I honestly,
I know enough people now
who've posted on my blogs,
even some close personal friends.
Uh,
one of them was a black belt in Aikido.
He went vegan and 18 months later
he's allergic to everything.
Like you had to go back.
But it,
it seriously just decimated as health.
So it's,
it's a careful thing to do,
but I know people who do and they're
very healthy guys like Mack Dansik,
he's very healthy and he's uh,
he's been a Vegan for years.
There definitely are
some very healthy vegans.
I'm friends with some Erin Simpson,
one of the guys are fights in the UFC.
Very healthy guy.
He's a Vegan.
Um,
how old are these guys?
Aaron I think is 36.
37 so I'm really curious
when I was younger,
what their blood work looks like,
I'd love to see like an antiaging
panel from one of those guys.
I don't know if any of
them has ever posted it,
but I'd love to just go through it and
look at their triglycerides from all the
fructose they eat.
I mean,
that's one serious thing.
There's c reactive protein.
Every antiaging physician
I've worked with,
and when I say that,
I run an antiaging nonprofit group
called Silicon Valley Health Institute,
SUV ahi.com or.org.
We've been around for 19 years,
bringing guys in like Aubrey de grey,
other like big time antiaging people
to give lectures and to a tee,
every single one of them
except one has said flat out,
I won't take a Vegan patient because
I cannot make them age less quickly.
Like it just doesn't work.
And these are the guys who like see
10 patients a day with carefully
demonstrated panels.
It,
the bottom line is it's,
I would love it if the Vegan diet was,
was safe and effective.
I was a raw vegan for about four
months and after that I became a Ra,
omnivore for another six or seven months
before I went off to Tibet and China.
I'm not eating raw yak and into bed.
No,
no.
I,
yeah,
it was kind of hanging
out from the mud wall.
I'm like,
you better cook that
Yak.
Huh?
Was He actually sorry.
It's actually awesome.
Some of the best meat I've ever had.
It's really,
it's better than grass fed beef.
Even like the best Primo grassfed.
Really?
Yeah.
Huh?
What do you think people
would know about that?
Well,
the problem is it only eats some kind of
weird moss that grows at high altitude
and it dies when you
bring it to low altitude.
So it's kind of a constrained supply.
Oh Wow.
That's fascinating to
seriously tough animal though.
Jakks yeah,
I mean they're,
they're ginormous.
Like most of the things
you see are only half.
Yeah,
calf cow.
But the real ones are bigger than a camp.
Tangy.
Tastes good.
I would think they'd be like real gamey.
Yeah.
Funky.
Pizza Yag Layman,
you know.
Oh yeah,
it was awesome.
So this is an incredibly fascinating
subject to me because I've always wondered
like what it is about certain people,
they store so much fat and certain
people just stay lean no matter what.
Some of that,
obviously it's genetics,
but what is wrong with their diet
that takes a person and just,
it blows them up to three 5,400 pounds.
I mean,
it's,
there's gotta be a,
this is a critical issue,
right?
Is it sugar?
Is it a,
what is it as imposters and
carbs that turn to sugar?
It's actually sugar plus inflammation.
So it's that combination of Omega six,
like excess Omega six oils plus sugar
and corn syrup and things like that.
What you're doing is you're basically
just just completely wrecking the
metabolism when you do that.
A mega six oils have lots
of polyunsaturated bonds.
I'm talking corn oil,
canola oil,
stuff like that,
and vegetable oil,
what happens,
their soils and other one,
every unsaturated bond in that oil can
oxidize and what oxidizes it is oxygen,
heat and light.
So most of these roles get
oxidized before you even eat them.
But in the body you try and make cell
walls out of them and when that happens
you end up with less flexible cell walls
that aren't able to express the insulin
receptors very well.
Right.
So we ended up with lots of problems like
that because we ended up getting these
oils that oxidize easily when
they're oxidized inside the body,
they make free radicals.
So you get general systemic inflammation
and you can measure these levels.
Like if you take a Vegan and you look
at their Omega six to Omega three ratio,
it can be 30 40 to one the
average American on a crap
industrial meat diet is at
40 to one right now.
My blood levels are 1.28 to one of my
Omega six to Omega three ratios and that
helps me to crank my inflammation way
down and it helps me to express healthy
insulin receptors so I don't
get insulin resistance.
I don't get Leptin
resistance and that lets me,
even now I could go out,
I can eat a relatively heavy sugar meal.
I don't get a coma from it even though
I used to get a coma from it when I
weighed 280 pounds or 300 pounds.
I can also go 18 hours without eating
and it doesn't bother me in the slightest
and that's a pretty big difference from,
I used to be the guy,
I'm like,
it's 1145 I got to,
I got,
we got to end this meeting right now
because I have to eat because if I need it
I'm going to kill someone.
You can go 18 hours.
Yeah.
In fact I did it yesterday.
I had my last meal at 4:00 PM last
night and then again at two today.
I guess that was a little
more than 22 hours.
No.
What do you say about people that say
that you should have like some sort of a
post workout?
Um,
sugary meal,
some like a lot of glucose,
high glucose,
a little bit of protein.
What do you think about that?
I looked at that and what you're trying
to do there is you're trying to spike
your insulin afterwards
because the insulin,
we have insulin like growth factor
IGF one which has caused you to build
muscles.
It's insulin light cause it has
the same effects as insulin.
So you had a lot of sugar spike your
insulin allegedly lay down more muscle.
There's a couple of studies I've seen and
I can't cite sources from memory right
now,
but what I,
what I recall from seeing them is that
it looks like the effect and Igf one
probably isn't as good
as you'd like it to be.
What I do after I work out is I
typically have a good amount of protein,
a good amount of fat and some starch,
not a lot,
and I choose low toxin starches,
which is kind of hard to do.
I've got the bulletproof diet up
on the site where it's a free,
but it's an infographic that basically
ranks foods based on three criteria and
if you get a bulletproof starch,
like a white rice that's properly
rents in cooked or a sweet potatoes,
butternut squash,
things like that,
what you're doing is you're getting your
carbs up enough that you can still even
stay in a state of ketosis.
Maybe,
maybe not.
But what you can do there is you can
reduce your stress hormone levels and that
eating right after you
work out drops cortisol.
If your cortisol doesn't get
dropped in that postworkout window,
you get a cortisol spike
that lasts for 48 hours,
so you're not going to get as much muscle.
It's absolutely critical to eat.
But do you need sugar or do
you need protein and fat?
I would tend towards protein and
fat with a small amount of starch.
So how did it get started that people
learned how to drink chocolate milk?
That was like the big thing for awhile
it was like chocolate milk is the best
post workout drink.
You know there's effects
from milk on IGF one as well.
Like milk will cause you to put on weight
because you to put on fat to build.
If you want to look up,
you know milk works for bulking up.
Why chocolate milk?
Because someone said,
oh it's raising the insulin some more,
but kind of look at
what's in chocolate milk.
At least make your own
with real chocolate.
What is in chocolate?
It's usually high fructose corn syrup.
Like terrible for you.
Yeah.
And plus you've got problems
with when you homogenized milk,
you take those fat droplets that your
body really needs and you put them through
a super fine screen under pressure,
which makes these extremely
fine fat droplets that your
body doesn't know how to
handle.
They can actually enter cells.
So imaginization can increase inflammation
and it causes weird fat reactions
that that your body's not ready for.
And also when they pasteurize the milk,
you get a case in and case
is an inflammatory compounds
depending on how it's
processed.
But it's a very careful protein.
I don't need any case and I know lots of
people who are just playing allergic to
it and I mean you've probably had people
in here talking about the China study.
That was an incredibly
misrepresentative book,
but one of the key points at the very
beginning was that case and can increase
inflammation and be
linked to liver cancer.
And that's actually true.
So man,
in order to get some protein,
you're getting case which
has been pasteurized.
You're getting fat and the wrong form,
you're getting high fructose corn syrup.
I could probably formulate a better
post workout drink using MCT oil,
like bulletproof flow talks and chocolate.
Maybe you could use honey.
Even like raw honey has a different effect
than say normal sugar does and normal
sugar has a different effect
on high fructose corn syrup.
What is the deal was corn?
Why?
Why do we use so much corn?
It's high fructose corn syrup and corn
is in so many different to everywhere.
Is that a lobby thing?
Is that,
yup.
Corn and soy are lobby things
and also farm subsidies,
right?
You know,
you grow corn and soy,
you get extra money from the
government for growing this stuff.
We've got the whole
Monsanto connection there,
which is just beyond evil.
From my perspective,
it's confusing,
very confusing that it's real.
It's very confusing.
If there's a company out there that's
trying to make these genetically modified
food and then force farmers to grow them.
And when you see the
suicide rates in India,
they're,
they're absolutely stunning.
I mean it's like they're having
suicides there every day.
All Day long.
People are killing themselves
because of Monsanto.
There's been hundreds of thousands of
suicides in India link to Monsanto.
It's,
it's really crazy.
These poor farmers,
there's even more profound evil going on.
And one of my pet peeves,
things I talk about and I've studied
extensively is called mycotoxins.
And these are toxins that form
from fungus in the environment.
And the combination of dupont
plus Monsanto is a shocking story.
Like 30 years ago,
dupont made this pesticide
called Benno mill.
And what been a mill did
is it killed all fungus,
like 98% of fungus it touched,
which is die.
Unfortunately the other 2% would
get like x man mutation turned on.
So whole plasmid level
mutation it's called.
What this means is that instead of
one gene mutating like nature does,
whole groups or deans
would mutate and get this.
A fungus can change plasmids,
plasmids like baseball
cards with other fungus.
So what's going on here is we create
an x men fungus that reproduce every 20
minutes 30 years ago,
and some of these new toxic
molds that are like Uber vicious,
you know that,
that poisoned people in their houses
and all I've had that happen to me,
you know,
Stacie buttress and Aspergillus in your
kitchen will mess your head up sometimes
permanently.
And what's going on is
Ben a made these toxic,
but then you spray roundup on soil.
Roundup completely
disrupts the soil microbes.
These are like the
probiotics of the planet.
Like our soil health is really important.
So now you get mutated x men stuff growing
in the soil and then you piss it off
with roundup.
You get 500 times more toxins and then
that mold that's left fusarium grows in
the corn.
In fact,
it's a major pests.
It's a major pest for corn in the u s you
get dried corn with toxic mold forming
fusarium in it.
It a majorly large percentage.
I don't know for this year,
some years it's up to 98% of corn
has this toxic mold growing in it.
What?
It's crazy stuff.
And this is not like any kind of weird,
you know,
conspiracy theory thing.
This is documented in
agricultural science,
just known in biochemistry that I know of,
tends to read the studies on
mycotoxins cause they're all like often
agricultural land
instead of unhealth land.
So you're saying that 98% of corn has
this microtoxin in it and it's not killed
by any production process turning into
bread or turning it into corn bread or
tortillas or anything like that?
It's a micro,
not micro.
I'm Yco like as in Miko,
like mushroom derived.
Yeah,
like my sales.
Right.
And some of it is killed.
We've heard of these mycotoxins before.
Aflatoxin.
Everyone knows that's a bad
one in peanuts or penicillin,
like a tiny little little capsule.
Penicillin,
which has just mold extract has
this profound effect on your body,
right?
Well,
there's other stuff out there that has a
profound effect on your body at a parts
per million level.
And I don't know if this
year 98% of corn is,
that's the maximum I found in my data,
but at least a third almost every year
in the u s of corn of dried corn product
that's out there like animal feed,
like Masa,
like corn tortillas has stuff in it.
And for,
sorry,
I missed three classes of toxins that
mess with your brain and with your
hormones and with your protein formation.
And that's why on the bulletproof diet,
I look first at macronutrients and then
I look at anti nutrients like mycotoxins
and hitch heterocyclic
amines and all the others.
And you gotta be a little careful in
your food if you want to like really kick
ass and be mentally focused all the time.
These are the things that get in
there and muck with your head.
Some people are more
sensitive than others,
but if you reduce the level
of these things in your diet,
you think better and that's one reason
you do the bulletproof diet in the
morning.
All you're drinking with bulletproof
intermittent fasting is low toxin coffee,
low talks and butter
and toxin free MCT oil.
You do that.
You've had nothing messing with your head.
Only good stuff,
no bad stuff.
Dad is absolutely fascinating
so everyone's being poisoned.
Essentially.
Everyone who's eating all these
corn products is being poisoned.
Yup.
At low levels they are and the links
between heart disease and cancer and
mycotoxins are very well established.
In fact,
the WHO researcher who's written the most
research of anyone on Mycotoxins as a
whole book,
this thick,
uh,
called Fungal bionics where he cites
900 different studies about the links
between atherosclerosis and cancer.
That's heart disease.
Direct quote from this author.
He says there was a known cause of
atherosclerosis and it is mycotoxins.
Pig farmers know this.
They know that if they get great these
grains that have mold growing in them,
they have test kits they can buy where
they test the grain because they know
they feed too much grain
to the key to the pigs.
The pigs will get lesions
in their arteries or the
pigs will lose their litter
before they can deliver it.
But what they do is they wait until
the pigs are far enough along.
Then they feed the cheaper toxic grain
to the pigs or the cows and that fattens
them up faster and it costs less money.
And the fact that some of that stuff
is still in the meet your problem.
Wow.
So when you're getting pork chops
are getting it cause they grain,
it all depends on who fed the pig.
Jesus Christ.
So when you're getting
steak you're getting that.
If you're not eating grass fed steak,
you're making a mistake.
And that's one of the reasons
you go on a Vegan Diet.
If you're eating really good quality,
non Moldy Vegan food,
you're going to get less toxins.
Like you compare a Vegan or vegetarian
versus standard industrial meat based,
you know,
meat and hydrogenated
fat and Msg Diet Man,
I would rather be a Vegan then a standard
American diet any day of the week.
The problem is that if I want to
for many,
many years have the highest energy levels,
the most focused with the
least amount of effort,
you're not going to be able to achieve
that on the Vegan diet and I don't think
you'll hit your very top level of
performance as a hundred percent Vegan.
You could probably be mostly Vegan,
but you're going to be missing
out on some things over time.
Like there's pretty good
research on my side about that.
This is,
it's,
it's unbelievable that you,
you sound so convincing,
but I'm too stupid to
know if you're right.
There's a lot of convincing
vegans out there too.
Yes,
there are.
Well,
you know there's a lot of people that
tell you how much it changed their life,
but my point is with a lot of
those peoples that generally,
there's not all,
but generally they come from a really
bad diet and then they start eating your
vegetables and they feel better.
Well,
of course you're going to feel better,
but I think your point,
it really does make a lot
of sense as to what is,
what is the optimum way to do it.
This is all stuff that
I'd never heard before.
I'd never heard it all meet has
some sort of low level Mike,
Michael,
Miko,
mycotoxins,
but it's the only
industrial meat like the,
I have a half account in my fridge.
It grew up three miles from my house.
It costs $3 and 50 cents a
pound and it's grass fed.
It never ate any grain.
It was well treated.
It was butchered humanely
and it tastes awesome.
Like he's really good meat and
I to do you have a big freezer?
Yeah,
just have a,
the cost 300 bucks at Costco.
It's not even that hard to do.
Just by the freezer,
toss it in the back of the car,
bring it home,
throw it in the basement and you've got
meat that costs a third of what it's
going to cost or,
or 20% of what it would
cost at whole foods.
I've got links on my site.
You can order a hundred pounds at a time
and just have it shipped to your house.
Jesus Christ.
But doesn't it taste
funky because it's frozen?
You know,
this is a funny thing about me.
When they hang meat to let it age,
what they're doing is they're letting
basically mold and bacteria in the
environment like work on the meat.
Well the links between those molds
and human health are not so good.
Think about it.
This is a mold that likes
to eat meat and Joe,
you and me are made out of meat.
So the incidence of low
level fungal infections,
like I don't need dry age meat.
That's cooked really rare cause they're
still active fungus that likes to eat.
What I made out of in there,
I don't think that's good man.
How do I not know about it?
So I burned calories.
Joe Is this meat?
That's it.
You just snort,
snort and mold.
So it turns out you want
the freshest of anything.
As soon as you kill it
and you drain the blood,
throw it in the freezer and
when you're ready to eat it,
take it out.
How many hours from the time it's killed,
butchered and then frozen.
The stuff that I have,
I actually specially requested it.
It was about two days.
Two days.
Yeah.
So they just meet laze
around for two days.
Yeah.
What they do is they hang it in a climate
controlled environment which lets all
the blood come out.
But typical like high end steak,
21 days,
sometimes up to like 64 days.
Dry Age.
Yeah.
And then you know,
drives me,
tastes amazing.
I'm not going to say that it's bad,
but the difference in how dry age meat
makes your brain feel versus fresh meat
that's been frozen right away
and then defrost it and cooked.
You will feel like a different
human being when you eat that stuff.
What is killed during
the freezing process?
Is there anything that's killed?
It's not about the killing,
although it can kill parasites like
they use that in now you freeze a Sushi
for a while at very low
temperatures to kill parasites.
What's going on is you're preventing
the formation of these basically
psychoactive compounds that form in
addition to those nice yummy flavors that
come from the east and the fungus
sending tendrils into the meat.
So that nice kind of soft,
mushy,
dry age meat.
Even if it's grass fed,
it has health impacts including
cardiovascular impacts
that are not present for
fresh meat that was frozen.
Wow.
But yet so delicious.
Nature's fucked us again man.
I still eat bacon,
no problems there.
Here's the thing,
why?
Why does dry cause dry age
does tastes pretty damn good.
It here's how we discovered dry a dry.
How long have we really had good freezers,
right?
Not that long.
And so you're going to kill a
giant cow a hundred years ago.
You're going to hang it in the coolest
place that you can find and you're going
to whack off pieces of an eat
it like kind of cal on the cop,
right?
Yeah,
I guess so.
I mean back then there must
have eaten a lot of rotten meat.
Just yeah,
keep it going.
Now did that have anything to do with the,
the appendix or was the
appendix for processing fiber?
What was the appendix
processing?
I don't think that there's a
scientific consensus there.
I've heard it.
It's a store for um,
uh,
for probiotics potentially
like the healthy bacteria.
Like that's like the
little storehouse for them,
but I've never heard a definitive,
this is why we had an appendix
that everyone agreed with.
So humans for a long time had to be able
to deal with a certain amount of fungus
and bacteria.
In fact,
wired magazine.
Yeah,
just published this whole thing like,
oh,
we've been focusing on the genome of the
bacteria in the gut and we just noticed
there's just as much fungus growing
in your gut as there is bacteria.
If we don't know anything about it,
she's as Christ.
How weird is it that we have organisms
that are essential to human survival and
they live inside of our intestinal tract.
They're essential.
If you don't have them,
you will die.
The question is,
are they apart from,
I mean that's a part of being human,
right?
If you're dead without them,
they're just like party
your repair system.
Yeah,
there the soldiers.
So the little soldiers,
that's what I,
when I tell people about probiotics,
I used to get sick a lot when I went on
the road until I really started getting
into Kombucha is my
favorite because it's easy.
I liked the way it tastes and I'll
drink a couple of those a day and I'm
covered.
And it's made a huge significant
impact on how many calls did I get.
I mean it's just they stopped,
they just stopped.
I love it.
And the way I explained to people,
I go,
it's like hell.
When you eat healthy bacteria,
it's like sending soldiers.
You have healthy soldiers,
they're going to go out and whack
all the shitty things that you touch.
Like it really does work that,
yeah,
but now think about this.
If you do that,
do drink your Kombucha and
then you go have a normal,
you know rabbi that was
fed industrial meat.
It's got antibiotics and that means they
use antibiotics cause they make animals
fatter,
faster so that it's not that they're
using it to keep him from getting sick,
they just want the,
the muscle striations.
They want the fat to
marble through the muscle.
So now you're eating that.
You just whacked those nice
bacteria that you put in your gut.
And that's why I'm kind
of militant when I go out.
I'll eat fish like non farmed fish,
wild caught fish long before I'm an
eat steak at a normal steakhouse.
If they say,
oh it's fed grass finished
steak,
I'm like double load me up.
I'll have two pounds of it.
But the rest of the time
when I'm on the road,
I'm,
you know,
you'll see in my backpack I've got,
smoke sockeye salmon.
That's stuff is as clean as it gets.
So when you go to a restaurant,
what were of still your EAD rather,
but it's hard to even get wild fish,
man.
A lot of fishes farmed fish like that
weird salmon where they actually changed
the color of the,
the,
the flash to China.
That's not right.
When you hit these prison bitch salmon,
the ones that you buy in the supermarket,
they have like this pale flesh.
It's like they just like
fuck it and it's mushy.
It's gross.
They feeding them pallets,
you know,
and the pellets are like soy and corn
and antibiotics plus ground up sardines
and it's,
they're,
they're environmentally destructive.
Like you shouldn't buy farmed fish on
principle because it's bad for the world.
Like our oceans are
already screwed up enough.
We don't need that.
It's also like,
it seems fucked up.
I mean it's,
it's,
it's fucked up enough that
you catch them with nets,
you know,
just swoop through an entire environment
and kill everything and rope it up and
that's fucked up enough.
But at least those were wild,
wild until that moment.
And then they got checked.
But to just live in
this fucking kitty pawn,
while they throw this
bullshit and on top of you,
that's all you have to eat
just seems fucking stupid.
I think w there's certain things that
people do to animals that are really
arrogant and zoos are one of them.
Ah,
and I just kind of break my heart
even though the real natural ones.
But I've been to zoos like in Cambodia
and all and like you see the stress
behavior in animals,
it's,
it's just horrible.
It shouldn't be allowed.
It I,
I'm a hypocrite because I go cause I want
my kids to see what animals look like
cause it's interesting.
But if I had my choice,
I would say don't let this
bring you back to the woods,
man.
Let them live in the jungle at the liver.
They live.
This is nonsense.
Like you either you either want to get
rid of them because they're dangerous or
you know,
leave them the fuck alone.
Those are those,
the two options,
the idea that you can take them and just
lock them in this little environment so
people can stare at them
as they paste in circles.
That's torture.
That's craziness.
And even let them kill
anything and you know,
it's bad.
Look what they feed those animals.
They all die like in a third.
The amount of time they live in the wild
and it's not just stress from being in
captivity and you're having people
throw cigarette butts at you.
It's because they feed them crap and
they're sort of figuring that out.
Oh look,
they keep dying and we keep having
surgery and doing all this weird stuff to
keep them alive.
Kind of like they do for people now.
They're giving them prison food,
poor fucking gorillas.
So sad.
[inaudible] watched him
pace around that thing.
I was like,
wow,
you know,
my two year old thinks it's awesome,
but you know,
to me it's,
it's,
it's kind of trippy eagles,
the eagles in this net,
the eagles couldn't fly.
It was crazy.
They get an Roi like a little bit and
then land and fly a little bit and you're
like,
oh my God,
they must be going nuts.
They fucking bald eagles
and they can't just sore.
Like they get sore man and float around
and they want to like kill rabbits and
things like that.
I'm pretty sure they're not getting much
of that going on even though pellets,
they're giving them dog shit.
And a can,
you know,
it's like,
it's terrible.
What are they feeding them?
They push out a little tray
of meat and the Eagle eats.
It's ridiculous.
We were that we would take away the one
thing that nature must have them set up
for a massive reward of
endorphins and of of,
you know,
Sarah,
whatever the fuck their little
brains produce a little lizard.
Excellent questions.
Evil Eyes.
You have a look in the eyes of an eagle.
What a creepy fucking eyeball.
Those things.
That Eagle is just representing
our country very well.
Joe,
look,
Eagle fly.
If you ever heard that video where I'm
that crazy dude that used John Ashcroft.
Remember John Ashbery?
Super Crazy.
Super Crazy,
but he has a song I remember.
Did we play on the podcast ones?
Yeah,
we won't play it again.
Just look up.
John Ashcroft.
Let the Eagle Soar.
Oh my God.
Or let the eagle fly.
What does it add?
Dubstep at the end of
it's probably better.
It's,
it's,
it's amazingly crazy.
Have you seen it a long time ago?
Yeah.
It's amazingly crazy if
she wants that sky diver.
Yes.
That was amazing.
Did you see that?
That's awesome.
I was hoping that a Ufo was going to
snatch him out of the sky on his way down.
That was an awesome,
that faint because doesn't
that something like,
you know,
like scaring a bunny rabbit that,
that just your body can't
take falling from space.
You almost did.
He said he was spinning and he said that
if he spent spun anymore he could pass
out and die.
And so he was like,
do I pull the rip cord and slow down
and I hit the record and he said,
I'm just going to do it anyway.
He didn't pass out.
Wow.
Yeah.
He was flipping and then he
leveled out somehow or another.
I don't know how he leveled
out the flying squirrel thing.
Just oh yeah,
he uh,
it was really weird to watch
them step off of it though.
That was really weird to be right behind
them with the camera and watch them
just drop on a site.
That's pretty epic.
That dude was in a balloon.
I didn't know you could take a balloon.
The space that's your daycare.
Just know that know who'd
want to take a balloon,
the space,
why haven't we done this already?
Why aren't their trips to
go to space in a balloon?
Hi Richard Branson should
check this guy out.
What's up rich?
And if you're right,
here's another question.
Is it possible you're hit by a satellite
cause don't satellites whip around the
earth?
Sure.
It wouldn't be going like 500
miles an hour or something to get,
they're usually probably
like not like states off,
you know like millions of miles off.
Like that almost hit me like
I'm smelling satellites.
It's the space junk.
So we didn't talk about this but like I,
I'm a geek.
Like I,
I'm a vice president at a computer
and that security company,
like Silicon Valley Guy and yeah,
we have like problems with space junk,
serious problems where they map it all
out and there's like storms were like
little nuts from like a Chinese
rocket from 40 years ago or whatever.
It was spinning around
probably not 40 years.
And they're like bullets.
I mean there's,
there hypersonic and they
poke holes in satellites.
They can kill people on space station,
so it's getting to be like,
my God,
it's kind of dangerous up there.
Jesus Christ.
Could you imagine sitting in
the fucking space day shooting?
You hear like bolts?
Yeah,
you're digging and you're like,
that's the whole cash is a hole right
to the other side and you look down,
your leg is bleeding.
They track all that stuff now
so they know if it's coming.
Oh my God,
they tracked the bolts
that are flying in space
because of how many of them are there?
Like hundreds of thousands now.
Oh my God.
Do you have like whole like you know,
leftover fueled capsules
and all this stuff?
I astronauts poop that.
They do.
I'm serious.
Like frozen.
You know things they'd like to buy it.
Frozen Turd and when
you're out on a space walk,
if it can happen.
I've had semi frozen Turd
Beam Debbie and it still hurt.
I can't believe that.
I can't believe there's hundreds of
thousands of pieces of junk up there.
That's insane.
Yeah.
No one's going to clean that either.
It's not like you can put a net up there
and scoop it all up because for most of
it came from military exercises.
Let's blow up a satellite in
orbit and see what happens.
Like,
oh,
it scatters crap all over orbit.
Yeah,
it's just an environmental problem.
Just like we have in our oceans
are somewhere else in the middle.
Sir.
So crazy that in the 60s when they first
started like thinking about going to
the moon,
they did the thing called
[inaudible] starfish prime,
where they shot a nuclear bomb up
into the atmosphere and blew it up.
They blew it up in the radiation belts.
Just let's see what happened
and what will happen though.
It's fucking crazy.
Nobody knows.
There's no money.
They had to go,
hey,
what are you doing?
Don't just fucking do
it to see what happens.
You guys crazy.
What's the benefit of shooting
a nuclear bomb in this space?
You crazy fucks theirs.
They've gotten nuts on that stuff.
It's interesting.
My grandparents met on the Manhattan
project like in Chicago before Los
Homeless.
My grandmother's a master's degree in
nuclear engineering in one like a lifetime
achievement reward for
nuclear engineering,
like one of two women ever.
So like I grew up in a
nuclear family like this,
but even there like could we stop
blowing those things up everywhere?
Like they're kind of useful in a war,
but like maybe blowing up a few hundred
of them around the planet isn't a good
idea.
Well,
have you ever seen the A,
there's an animated Gif file or maybe
it's a video that shows all of the,
on the globe shows you a map of the
world and it shows all of the nuclear
explosions in their correct
order that have taken place,
all the tests and it's like
boom,
boom.
And the Soviet Union ones pump,
pump,
pump.
Wow.
Want to be awesome.
You should link to that
video
of all of the nuclear explosion.
It's just to try,
you'll,
you'll find it.
Um,
but I've seen it,
it's fast.
There's been like more than a hundred.
Yeah.
A hundred nuclear explosions.
I did not know that.
It's really scary.
And some of the things that happen there.
We have a kind of a rise
in thyroid cancer and gee,
you get radioactive iodine out there and
have these having environmental impact.
And some of the stuff we
don't even understand like
low frequency vibrations on
the Earth's crust from those things.
There's biological effects from the
reverberation of the Earth's crust here to
the Schuman residence.
Um,
when funders strikes,
you get this reflection between the eye
on the sphere and the earth's crust and
it creates a,
uh,
basically a,
a brown to 10 hearts.
I forget the nine point
something hertz frequency.
And if we don't have this,
like we don't work very well as humans.
And in fact,
in the Russian space program,
they actually figured out that
they were not doing well at all.
They actually replicate
this inside the spacecraft.
Now make a rumble or go sound,
you don't hear it.
It's like an electrical thing.
It's a super low frequency EMF.
So this,
this EMF that's given out by thunder and
lightening is actually actually has a
positive effect on human beings.
It's like a timing signal.
If we don't get it,
we don't do so well.
It's right in the Alpha
brainwave spectrum.
Oh yeah.
In fact,
I have a human way of residence,
uh,
creation thing in my,
in my house.
Like it's one of things that
lowers biological stress.
When you have a Schumann resonance
that you're low level biological,
like electrical systems can sync to,
it lowers the stress.
If you have like Wifi routers and
things like that all over the place,
your body tries to like find a signal
and it doesn't get one very well.
And when it doesn't get one very well,
it just raises your cortisol levels.
Your body is trying to find a signal.
What do you mean by that?
So there's an electromagnetic signal on
the earth and it sounds kind of goofy to
be honest,
but one of the ways you can do
this is with an earthing mat.
And I kind of went out on a limb and I
started promoting these as like this,
this thing rocks.
And what this is,
is,
is a mat.
It's made out of electrically
conductive fibers.
It's just silver woven into a sheet and
you plug it into the round part of the
electrical outlet at your house.
So just the grounding part.
Are you sticking into the earth,
like drop it out the window on a
wire and stick it into the ground?
You do this and it normalizes your
quarters logs Grecian at night,
your sleep improves really dramatically.
Especially for jet lag.
I absolutely will not travel without my
earthing mat because I don't get jet lag
at all anymore.
Like it's just a nonissue what craziness.
Lance Armstrong uses this on the Tour
de France in order to recover faster,
like you recover from injuries faster
when you're grounded and there's an
electrical thing,
you can measure this happening there.
There's two effects.
One is you build up a charge on your
body and you can just pick this up with a
meter.
You were walking around indoors or wearing
shoes like rubber shoes all the time.
So we basically just the error over
our skin builds up a static charge.
When you get a spark,
you know,
like in the desert,
you know you touched the
most static electricity.
That's an extreme example of it,
but our bodies kind of
work like big batteries,
like we have different electrical fields
in different electrical potentials
inside the body.
So when you spend about 20 minutes
walking in grass barefoot or laying on
earthing mats being on the beach,
what you're doing is you're dropping the
extra charge that's built up over time.
And when you do that,
you heal faster.
You really do recover faster.
It,
it's profoundly amazing how well it works.
Um,
there's cardiologist's recommending this,
there's a whole book written about this.
I'm like,
I've heard about people lying in
the grass sleeping in the grass.
That's why to help them heal.
I thought this was such bs,
but like I used to fly to Cambridge,
England every six weeks.
I was a vice president of the company
based out there and I'd fly from,
from the bay area out there.
And that's like the worst commute
ever in terms of time zones,
like you're flying east.
And I would go and I'd start
in the morning when I land,
I'm going to exercise to raise my body
temperature and that's going to be how I
hacked my jet,
my jet lag.
And one day I did yoga in the park because
like the only day of the year it was
not rainy in England.
And uh,
that's how I had no jet lag.
I'm like,
yes,
my exercise works.
Then the next time I do it in hotel rooms,
the same exact thing and
had horrible jet lag.
I'm like,
what is it?
And I finally like,
like understood years later what,
what had really been the variable
that I didn't know to look for.
So this is one of the things,
it's like a $70 little item and you
try it and you just know it works.
I wish marijuana was legal to grow cause
I went to a grow room once in this dude
had this,
uh,
he was illegal.
It was illegal set up.
I go into the back room and he's got
this room larger than this room and it's
filled with these really
happy cannabis plants.
And they have there have been taken care
of with the perfect fertilizer and the
perfect soil composition.
There's misters or going off constantly
and there were really healthy and
vibrant and you walk into that room and
you feel them and it sounds like hippie
bullshit,
but I wasn't even high.
I walked in that room stone
cold sober and I was like,
Whoa,
this,
this is like,
like they have a frequency.
Like there's like it's an
intangible thing that I sense,
I can feel it but I wouldn't know
how to describe what it's doing.
I do a lot of work at that level
with the biohacking I talk about.
So you have this reptilian brain that's
responsible for low level systems in the
body.
It's the same thing as salamander
has and it census stuff,
but it does it so fast that you
don't even know what happened.
Like if you put your hand on a hot stove,
you'll pull your hand away before
you know the stove was hot.
And that's an example
of this thing in action.
So what it does is it picks up all
kinds of stuff from the environment.
A lot of stuff we don't
even understand yet,
but it does it and it matches patterns
so fast that you might just get like a
wisp of an intuition from it.
But what's going on there is like the,
the animal part of you is totally picking
up all these things and you can train
yourself to,
to basically be more sensitive to what it,
what it's telling you and you can train
yourself and train it to behave better
because that reptilian brain is
what gets us in a lot of trouble.
It's all how you know when
someone's upset at you,
when someone's upset at you,
even if they're trying to
pretend that they're not,
you know,
there's somethings off that
giving you a certain feel.
Now I'm going to sound
like a total hippie Wacko.
It's,
which I'm not too late at.
Darn.
So you're on this show.
I'll take that.
So I'm an advisor to this company called
the heart math institute and heart math
makes a heart rate
variability training device.
These guys are Silicon Valley geeks.
They spent 20 years looking
at like meditation and how
you quantify meditation,
like what's going on in the body.
And it turns out by looking at the
spacing between your heartbeats,
you can totally change the way your
brain works in the way your body works.
And in the course of their research,
they went out and they did some really
heavy duty science and there's actually a
magnetic field around your heart.
It's tipped it like a 12 degree angle way.
It's shaped like a tourist,
like a donut.
And they know which direction the fields,
uh,
move on it and everything.
So it's the most electrically
active part of your bodies.
You're hired and get this.
When a human walks into
a stall with a horse,
before they touched the horse,
the horse is heart rate variability
will change to match the humans.
We have a field of fact on the people
around us and it's an electromagnetic
field that's heart-based and like we
can measure it and people get pissed off
when they hear this and then they
just think everything I say is crap.
It's not like a,
I know the scientists who
are behind this and B,
I'm a certified heart
math executive coach.
Like I use this to take people who are
super high performers who are tweaking
because of their stress and to teach
them to consciously basically use their
prefrontal cortex.
They're human most evolved part of the
brain to to train and take control of the
reptilian brain and when you do that
there's measurable changes in the spacing
of your heartbeats and there's a change
in the field or on your heart as well.
When you do that,
that's what you're,
that's what you're feeling there.
Someone's pissed off at you.
They could not say a word and you might
not even see their face when you just
have a feeling.
We also know Bobby is letting you
know some shit might be going down.
I'm catching something bad
smells and in fact one of my,
one of my buddies is a special forces
guy and he actually wasn't technically
trained special forces guys.
He was a long range patrol officer
guy and he told me one day,
he said,
Dave,
what we learned out in the field,
he said,
if you're in someone's sites,
you can feel it.
He said,
if someone's got a gun
pointed at you like you're,
your body heats up.
Like,
like literally how the heck
could this be possible?
But the bottom line is we have
all sorts of weird senses.
We also know if we hook you up Joe to
like weird galvanic skin response sensors
and then you're sitting there if
someone's staring at you will be able to
measure your body responding to the stair
even if they're staring at your back.
Like there's all kinds of crazy stuff
in our bodies we haven't even really
explored yet.
Do you think those are evolving senses
or do you think those are just like
really sort of intangible senses
that we haven't quite defined?
They're not evolving senses.
Their old senses.
Those were there long before.
You know what?
What makes the the frog
move before the Eagle John,
before the eagle dives for it,
right.
It's those kinds of senses.
It's a very,
very low level survival oriented census.
Um,
you sure they're not evolving,
they're not getting better.
Maybe.
I think what's happening is that our
ability to access them from our prefrontal
cortex is evolving.
And that's one of the things I
spend a lot of my own time on.
I spent $20,000 and seven days hooked
up to an EEG machine to learn how to do
like advanced zen meditation.
That takes 40 years.
I didn't seven days.
And what you're really doing there is
you're just learning how to have the
prefrontal Cortex,
your human brain talk to
the low level systems.
And when you do that,
like you can unleash creativity and
intelligence and intuition in ways that,
you know,
most people aren't that familiar with.
What do you think is going on when you
see people that are our kids usually that
are autistic but they're
super genius in one area.
Like there was one kid that was making,
uh,
he was composing a symphony every nine
days or something like that and they were
really good.
It was really good music.
And then there's a kid who can look out
a window and out of an airplane and the
entire skyline
as he sees it perfectly.
Like do you think that that's evolving
possibilities in the brain that are just
starting to sort of pop up?
I don't.
You don't.
And I say that I had all the symptoms
of Asperger's syndrome till I was in my
mid twenties like obsessive
compulsive disorder,
oppositional defiant disorder.
I didn't know anyone's name,
like I wouldn't make eye contact,
all that kind of stuff.
I stuttered a little bit and I've done
a lot of work with the autism community.
In fact,
one of my goals in this book that I'm
writing to the better baby book that comes
out in January is to have less kids
with autism because you can handle
neurological inflammation
even in the womb,
so there's less likelihood
of it happening later.
What we can do though is we can take
a fully functioning neurologically
functioning adult and we can hit them
with really strong magnets in their head
and we can turn on autistic
skills and non autistic people.
So you can suddenly draw the most
amazing thing ever when you have a 10 ton
magnet focused on your head.
Whoa.
Oh yeah.
So this is some serious brain hacking
stuff like that fucking dude from the
expert and that magneto dude,
I hadn't thought of it like that.
Yeah,
that's exactly what it is.
It is Hema goddamn genius with
that magnet helmet on member.
Yeah.
And they're doing this like in a,
uh,
in neuroscience laboratories right now.
Like they have this really focused
thing that that shines a magnet and it
activates a specific part of your brain.
You can even do it to some extent
with the stuff having my backpack,
like a cerebral electrical
stimulation or tdcs,
you can run a current through part
of your brain and turned it on.
It wasn't turned on before and as
long as there's electricity there,
it's turned on.
So I think what's going on here
is the wiring and autistic kids,
they have chronic neurological
inflammation that's
environmentally mediated and
these you have problems with
the biology and their gut too.
So what we can do though is we can learn,
okay,
these autistic kids have these skills.
All of us have these skills too.
They're just not trained
and they're not turned on.
If you use technology,
you can train your brain to do crazy
stuff in very short periods of time so you
can gain these kind of powers without
having to give up the ability to socialize
for instance.
But a kid looking out a window and and
being able to capture the exact skyline
and then put that to paper as he,
you know,
I don't know if these are
classically trained artist.
I think he just does it.
That is a really special skill.
It's a special skill,
but I'll bet you that if we took six
months and we use those magnets and things
like that,
we can,
we can explore how his brain works and
teach your brain to do the same thing.
There's a lot of things out there that
are way teachable that you wouldn't think
are,
it's all just about
interfacing with the brain.
And the way we do it now
is really inefficient.
If I have a gigantic magnet on my head,
boy,
I played better pool.
Uh,
I think it depends on how much
the magnet weight is probably,
well,
I mean,
as far as like the frequent,
it needs something,
it's not something you'd wear.
It's not something you're
wearing this little bit.
Laceless.
When I say 10 tons,
I mean like this is a 10 ton
thing that that changes it.
And there's various like
articles from neuroscientist,
they went in,
they did the test and they drew
like the most amazing artwork.
Uh,
or in the military they do other things
like that with more with electricity.
But they'll say,
oh look,
this person got a stimulation here.
And they went through the shooting
simulation and they killed everyone
completely.
Whereas the last time they
had no skills at all real.
Oh yeah.
So like your brain is
like such an amazing toy.
You can completely change it.
But here's the thing you want,
you want to maximize this performance.
You need to myelinate
the nerves in your brain.
Myelination makes a nerve carry electrical
signals 3000 times faster than a non
myelinated nerve.
So first you have to
form the synapse apps,
which is called synaptic genesis.
And you do that through relatively
short amounts of practice.
You know,
the first time you learned,
well,
the first time you learned
to balance on your bike,
right?
Like you've,
you've learned how to do it.
It doesn't take long from
then on though to get it.
So it's just automatic.
That's what repetition does.
And you've had a lot of pro sports guys
and here they talking about 10,000 times
and repetitions.
The reason 10,000 times works
is because you're myelinating.
But here's the thing,
what's my island made out of?
Fat,
cholesterol,
Coleen.
So what you need to do is you need to
be cranking up on those kinds of foods.
And if you're going to be on a low fat
or a Vegan Diet that doesn't have any of
the saturated fats and as low and Coleen,
you're probably gonna have
a harder time myelinating.
It's gonna be harder for your brain
to do what it was meant to do.
So synaptic speaking,
it's harder to learn things.
Yup.
If you don't have enough fat,
you've got to have fat for
your brain to function.
I mean,
your brain is made out of fat,
but you don't want the wrong fat.
You don't want fat from a
stupid cow that ate corn.
No,
you're done.
You're all stupid.
Yeah.
And you don't want fat that's
been impregnated with toxins.
So you got to have grass fed meat.
You got to have it from some sort of
a reputable source where you know that
they're not feeding the any antibiotics.
How do you put the magnets on the cows,
Joe?
That's awesome.
I blew my fucking mind.
Yes.
Magnet Fed beef.
It's the cows started walking
up to the fence going,
I think we can get through it.
We just knock one of
these fucking things over.
The magneto helmet with the horns on it
to match of cows started figuring out
that it just fuck us up.
The corn just grows there.
Just let it grow.
It will grow by itself.
I found that video.
If you wanted to watch
the nuclear explosion.
Yes.
Yeah.
Let's see this.
This is crazy,
Matt.
This is,
by the way,
just America.
There's one of the world.
Oh,
this is the whole world.
here it goes here.
See how it'd be like soccer,
soccer.
Hiroshima.
Yeah.
This is so creepy.
We're so nuts.
Here's a crazy statistic that we figured
out in a podcast from the invention of
the airplane to someone using it to
drop a nuclear bomb on someone took less
than 50 years.
That's pretty impressive.
That's insane.
Wow.
Think about that as like a world changing.
Yeah.
It makes Moore's law look kind of sissy.
That's pretty amazing.
You know,
50 years later,
the dropping nuclear bombs out of them.
Russia starts jacking some off.
Fair.
Boom son.
There we go.
It starts just getting crazier
and crazier after this.
Right now we're up to eight from America.
One from Russia,
so not the sound of
how long has video
cause for the folks at homeless,
18 minutes of explosions,
but a lot of them were in,
there's a lot of Soviet Union.
Look at all those ones in Nevada.
It just goes crazy.
Nevada just lights up
like a Christmas tree.
They were all in Nevada.
All Nevada,
Britain.
How dare you?
Sons of bitches in the ocean.
Yeah,
you cowards.
But I'm in the ocean.
Look at Nevada.
Oh my God.
So scary.
They're all Nevada and explains Nevada,
doesn't it?
Fuck yeah.
Does Las Vegas right there?
It explains the reason
why it's allowed to exist.
I mean they do nuclear tests,
explains the airport.
They also bury a,
they bury a lot of nuclear waste
out there and not in Vegas,
but and look at Russia.
It's still glowing.
Scary shit man.
Oh my God.
More Devonta look at that.
And that's something 1955 looking at
how many of them are going off in Nevada
that is fucking bananas.
And compare that to like the recent
a nuclear reactor leak in Japan.
I don't know if this might be worse.
I don't know.
I think,
uh,
I don't know which one lasts more.
Yeah,
that was pretty brutal.
But they also have shit
buried out there too.
They're storing nuclear waste out there.
Yeah.
Spent nuclear rods and all kinds of other
shit that they think will be toxic to
the end of time.
We're just so ridiculous.
It's just so weird that we would have
something like that and just fucking start
look at this.
Wow.
It's kind of sounds like music.
Look how many
balms have gone off.
300 moms
and we're still in the 1960 like we
haven't even gotten into the mind.
It's a 1959 and there's been 300 bombs.
Wow.
This is really hard to watch,
but no kidding.
Total down here.
They were so stupid back.
Do you have any Justin Bieber
videos we can watch and stuff?
Yeah,
I think we should kill that.
Brian,
what are you concerned about?
Like the toxic shit that's
going to happen from Fukushima.
Is that going to affect people
that live here on the west coast?
Yeah,
it is.
I mean the,
the plume,
so to speak,
is making its way over here.
Now what does that mean?
We're actually finding a huge amounts
of wreckage that are hitting the shore
now.
In fact,
up where I live in British Columbia,
like it,
it's a big thing.
They're finding like motorcycles
and something like hundred ton,
like cement docs that sort
of walks wash up and like,
how do I get rid of this?
Like it's indestructible.
Oh my God.
A cement fucking doc that
was taken from Japan.
Yeah,
it broke free and it floated all the way
over here and it's like on the beach.
What's amazing is that
it's a little baby tsunami.
That ain't shit compared
to what could happen.
Oh yeah.
So that's happening.
But they say that the stuff that's
radioactive hasn't reached there yet.
So they're starting to,
they're starting to have a
Geiger counters on the beach,
like for the drunk cleanup crews to
see if they're finding this stuff.
So the question is,
what's it going to do to fish out here?
I show up at my sockeye
salmon is radioactive free.
And that said,
you know,
I,
I think taking iodine
iodine is a good idea.
I do that.
How does potassium iodine protect you?
Well,
if the form of radioactivity that
you're getting is radioactive iodine,
it protects you from getting
thyroid cancer years later.
The problem is that some of the
radioactive stuff coming out,
Fukushima may not be in an,
I died for him.
So I had,
I may not do much for you.
There's some evidence that asked us
Anthon which comes from Krill is pretty
protective as well.
So that's probably a good thing to take.
So krill Krill oil,
should you take it in that form?
I prefer Krill oil to fish oil.
I take Krill oil and I put,
uh,
and since I put,
I buy a form that has asked
as Anthony [inaudible],
which naturally occurs in the Krill,
it's the stuff that makes krill red.
It's just a really potent antioxidant
that has a good effect on radioactive
stuff.
This is a podcast that is going to test
your writing Shit Down Abilities Ladies
and gentlemen,
because this is a plug guys,
we're going to have to go back
[inaudible] assault by the way.
Jakks salts 11 it'll make Yag salt.
You Liar.
You're a fucking fibber.
How dare you.
Yeah,
I've got to get,
I'm going to go right to full wholefoods
right from here and get some fucking
Siberian salt or Tibetans salt.
Either one's good.
It tastes pretty good.
Like I like taking friends who are
not into health and you're like,
just try this salt and not quite,
you carry white vial of powder over
international borders with you.
Yeah.
Do you ever get tweaked on never.
It's weird.
I,
I mean I have like my upgraded whey
protein and collagen powder and like all
kinds of stuff that I should look like
I'm carrying kilos of random stuff.
But no one ever thought to ask you to
trust it or they never actually one time
I've had my whey protein
tested more often.
They checked my coffee cause
I don't drink hotel coffee.
It makes me feel crappy.
I just,
my coffee.
So I bring it with me just like,
you know,
beans or ground up coffee every time that,
oh,
what's that?
And then they open it and they seems
like they just want to smell it maybe,
I don't know.
Well it is that also the
people how drugs and coffee.
It's the easiest way because it does,
it stops the dogs from
smelling the marijuana.
You know,
it's funny,
I have a little a heard we've heard,
I have a little canister,
I put it in there that that's got a
desk again that like absorbs moisture.
So I mean it looks like I've got a little,
a little canister of drugs
inside my coffee and twice
I've had people say what's
in there and like keeps
the coffee dry and they,
they just don't stop me.
And I fly like a hundred times a year,
like very often.
Wow.
I drink a Trenta of coffee
every single day and then,
then I eat my first meal
about eight o'clock at night.
Nice.
That,
does it seem like,
I used to put butter in my coffee now?
Is that what you would recommend?
I would try it.
I seriously,
what if you're eating nothing else?
Yeah,
yeah.
I would try just some fat,
no sugar,
no protein,
but when you do that,
even just a tablespoon,
you may find that you have a lot more
energy throughout the day and splinters.
Okay,
like artificial sugar or
just stay away from it.
Just do Stevia if you're
going to do anything.
Yeah,
you can do is,
I will talk to a little bit was
that a tall won't raise your own,
stolen enough to matter,
but if you do a lot of Xylitol
and you're not used to it,
you'll get the runs like you'll take made
the bulletproof coffee with Stevia and
it was fucking delicious.
What was addicted to it?
It's really good,
but the problem is you're a lazy
bitch and you're not going to,
let's be honest,
you're not going to fucking get some
grass fed butter and melted and blend it.
You don't have to melt it and just
like toss the butter in the blender,
pour the hot coffee right in there
and hit blend for 2030 slave.
I may do that.
Needed to get one of you.
I'll get butter,
get Yulia butter and you can
get sent to your oil to you.
You know you could get groceries
now just delivered to your house.
It's amazing.
And it's not that much money.
Like you just go online and pick out
what you want and then it's just like,
all right,
we'll see you on an hour.
Like a pizza.
That's pretty sweet.
Yeah.
Wow,
that's amazing.
I didn't know that.
Yeah.
And plus butter keeps forever.
You can buy like 20 sticks of it and
toss it in the freezer and you'll have
butter coming out your eyes like so you,
you want to make sure when you go to
like organically raised beef is not good
enough.
It has to be grass fed,
organically raised.
You can take organic corn,
organic soil and organic Twinkies and
feed them to an organic cow and still sell
it as organic meat.
Like the standards are pretty low.
We keep,
Twinkies can be organic.
If they make one,
you can feed it to an organic
cow and it's still organic.
There's no standards
for what the cows eat.
It's just whether or not
what they ate was sprayed.
Oh,
I see.
Okay.
Um,
so but so for a lot of folks it's kind
of difficult to find grass fed meat in
your area.
Isn't it like a lot of
traditional supermarkets?
It is.
If you're,
you know,
in the middle of nowhere.
But here's the thing,
like Fedex and ups deliver everywhere.
It's cheaper to buy grass fed meat online
than it is to buy like a decent cut of
meat in a grocery store.
Like if you're going to buy grass fed
hamburger from some of the best places on
earth,
like I've like tested
different places on my site.
Like I have a whole series
is about grass fed beef.
You can get it for five bucks a pound,
like for grass fed,
perfectly treated animals.
Wow.
That's fucking really good.
Yeah.
And so like,
even if you're on a budget,
like okay,
eat a lot of eggs because
they're cheap and you know,
supplement with grass fed beef,
you had a half a pound a day,
it's going to cost you $2 and 50 cents.
Do you ever buy just fat?
Do you say like,
send me some fat.
I've bought beef tallow.
The problem is what's called,
yeah,
it's beef towels just rendered beef fat.
The problem is that the rendering process
is really finicky plus 15 finicky.
Well,
if you're going to render fat,
you need to have enough water in it in
order to render it so it doesn't oxidize.
One of the problems,
especially in the Paleo community,
and it drives me nuts.
People like Bacon,
like,
okay,
I love my bacon.
I'm a bacon snob.
I like,
I make my own bacon.
But what you've,
you've got to do though
is not overcook the oils.
If you,
if it's spitting all over the place and
there's smoke coming off the pan and
you're Bacon's crispy,
you've oxidized the fat.
And one of the things on the bulletproof
diet and I'm really focused on is like,
how do I get inflammation down?
So if you fry the crap out of your food,
then what you're getting
is inflammatory oils.
Even if they came from a good cow,
you're also getting delicious baked in.
That's a problem.
You're getting delicious bacon.
But here's the thing,
you put your stove on like three or
four and you cook the Bacon for longer.
All the fat melts out of the Bacon.
The Bacon does not going
to get all super crispy,
but it's a chewier begging,
right?
It's,
it's a little chewier but it's not like,
like bad.
She'll be like uncooked
bacon still awesome.
I like chewy big,
but I'll do like that fucked
up crispy Bacon Bacon.
It totally.
And like,
it's like we have like fried
Mozzarella too,
but like,
and he got to like choose
where you go on the spectrum.
What is it about fried things?
It's so horrible for you.
What does it do to your body?
It's mostly the damage fats.
They come in and your body's just like,
what do I do with this?
Fat?
Just can't process it
because it's overcooked.
Yeah.
It's like,
how do I,
how do I detoxify this?
So it's basically spitting out free
radicals and then you try and build cell
walls and hormones out of
this fat and your body.
Just like I do,
I do that.
I don't have the raw ingredients.
Why is it so fucking delicious
that I would love to know.
I think what?
What happens there for real,
right?
Like Kentucky Fried Chicken.
God Damn.
Well that Shit's good.
That's MSG and gluten and stuff ever.
It is.
I like it.
Yeah.
It was really MSG in gluten.
Oh Geez.
In like everything.
You know what?
It's God damn wonderful.
Don't change a thing.
Kentucky Fried Chicken.
We won't even talk about
Msg and obesity after that.
Yeah.
Well let's talk about how to
think about food in general,
whether it's Vegan or not.
Cause Google,
please explain though.
What did what,
what it does when your body takes in a,
just like Kentucky Fried
Chicken or anything.
Some of it's hydrogenated oil,
fried French fries and chips.
So we don't make healthy cell walls or
hormones or anything else in our body
made out of fat.
We didn't even burn
hydrogenated fat very well for,
uh,
for fuel.
So it basically is,
the liver has to detoxify it.
So it goes to the liver.
Liver was like,
Oh God,
what I do with this stuff.
So it starts using up the
glutathione in your liver,
which is the main detoxing enzyme.
It starts trying to figure out
how to break down these oils,
like were designed to take basically a
raw animal in and process it and to break
all those fats down into
reassemble them into our body.
We're not,
we're not meant to take those things in.
So what you get is actually a big rush
of white blood cells when you eat like
heavily cooked meat and the
oxidized fried fats and it actually,
it looks like an immune
response and your body's like,
okay,
I gotta do something about this.
So it does what it can to
build healthy cell walls,
but you get hungry after
you eat fried food.
If you ever noticed that,
like you feel full for well and afterwards
like I want like sugar or something,
the craving that you want for sugar,
they're either comes from the
MSG or it comes from your livers.
Like could I have some more fuel to use
to oxidize this stuff so I can excrete
it now instead of building it in?
Wow.
I never noticed that.
I usually feel like it's such a fat loser.
Oh yeah.
So you don't get like
hungry like your next meal.
You're like,
I don't like random cravings.
Okay,
cool.
Myself off I chicken.
Yeah,
but,
but I do like it like,
you know,
when I like it,
I like it like cold with hot sauce,
like watching stupid,
something stupid on TV.
It's a good snack.
Kentucky Fried Chicken,
you know the stuff tastes good.
I don't eat that stuff anymore.
I'm a delicate flower I guess
cause I weighed 300 pounds.
I just feel like crap.
I need it now.
Yeah.
I feel like crap when I needed to,
but I don't feel like
crap while I'm eating it.
That's the problem.
That's a fight while I'm eating it.
I'm loving it.
I'm loving the crispy outside
mixed with the hot sauce.
So if they had Kentucky Fried Kale,
would you try that?
My,
he kale all the time.
I mean I would do,
I eat kale chips.
I bike.
A lot of Kale chips have been
eaten those lately for snacks,
but I don't know what
they're the cheese out of.
You know the cause.
It's some weird Vegan.
It's usually new use.
It's usually a nutritional yeast,
which is,
I don't even want to talk about
what that does to your health.
Bad.
Yeah,
it's bad.
God dammit.
So fucking Kale chips are bad.
Nosy Kale chips don't have to be bad.
It's just what they
used to make him cheesy.
[inaudible] motherfuckers so cheesy.
Kale chips or bad.
If they're using vinegar
to make the cheesy flavor,
they're fine,
but most of them,
they use nutritional yeast
and they see what I could.
I have so many studies about how come
I knew they tasted too fucking good.
Yeah,
I knew it while,
sorry man.
These cheesy Kale chips are wonderful.
Why do you think they're so
addictive and you're like,
ah,
yeah,
you fucking God dammit Vegan people.
How dare you?
How dare you get me to eat
your shit that's bad for you,
but yet delicious.
There's going to be a huge storm on
Twitter about people saying nutritional
yeast has B vitamins.
And I'm like,
yeah,
and look at the,
just go to pub med and Google cancer
and nutritional yeast and see what you
find.
So the cheese is not a cheap,
it's actually a clump of organisms.
That's what the yeast is.
Yup.
It's like a,
it's like bakers and brewer's yeast.
Yeah.
Wow.
And then how they make it like a cheese,
they just,
well you actually kind of has
a cheesy flavor on its own.
So they take that and they
mix it with some other,
usually like a nut,
like a ricotta,
like or like a Vegan ricotta thing.
I mean I've been like,
uh,
I still eat a lot of like vegan dishes
just under the weird soy and crap.
Like if it's made out of raw vegetables
chopped up finally with enough good fat
in them,
like Avocados and some of
the healthier food out there.
Right.
So I'm,
I'm a pretty good in the kitchen,
like with raw food.
And the problem is you add
nutritional yeast to it,
it makes it inflammatory.
It's just not very good for him.
So that's just those kale chips.
You can get the regular Kale chips,
but that aren't quite
as God damn delicious.
I'm sorry Joe Mother fuckers.
I knew,
I knew it couldn't have possibly
die from cheesy Kale chips.
You're not concentrating on the
time maximizing your potential.
That's why I think this
is so far on the spectrum,
like,
okay,
if you ate cheesy Kale chips every day
for the rest of your life compared to
potato chips,
you,
you fucking rocked it.
Okay.
That's why everything on the
bulletproof diet is a spectrum.
It's like this is better than this,
but like this is a lot better than this,
so you don't have to be perfect.
If you,
you know,
if you want to identify a
goalpost for perfection,
just kind of move in that direction
and you'll be way better off.
And most people fail in their
diets because they feel like,
oh I,
I did it wrong.
Now I lose.
I'm like,
you didn't do it wrong.
You could have done a lot worse.
You could have done it better,
but like you're somewhere in the middle.
And the truth of the matter is,
I'm always in the middle too.
Like,
okay,
I had a grass fed cow but you know,
was it slaughtered by you know,
an ordained minister.
I fail if I know,
but like,
like there's probably some way of
making it slightly more perfect.
It wasn't massage every day.
I wouldn't want a minister to kill my cow.
I don't know if I went to dummy.
I actually tend to lose
count agree with you.
Like I don't know if I don't
like how blessed by the church,
bless it before you eat it,
but there has to be like some bizarre
thing you could do that's better.
Like then again,
if someone really
believed in the blessing,
maybe they would impart some
sort of an energy into the thing.
That sounds ridiculous.
But what we were talking about before
about people literally having some sort of
an environmental effect,
some sort of an effect on
all the people around them.
How these,
look,
you
don't want some asshole killing your cow.
I'll tell you flat out,
I do not want a cow that was
tortured before it was ill.
It changes the hormones at all?
I think it changes the taste and
there's an energy thing there.
I mean,
call me a psycho hippie or whatever,
but I've done a lot of
intuitive like training of my,
my,
my heart and of other parts of my
body with electronics and like,
I dunno,
there's something not right about like,
you know,
some statistic asshole,
torturing your cow,
killing it and then feeding it to you.
Like it's face,
it's wrong.
Well it is.
And have you ever seen the
way they do kosher cows?
Oh,
it's brutal.
It's those machines then.
It's crazy.
Well,
it's supposed to be done by a rabbi.
It's supposed to be done by a rabbi.
Rabbi supposed to slice
the neck of the cow,
but you're,
you're supposed to do it that way.
That's how he killed a cow.
You slice his neck and it takes a while
for him to die and it's not fucking
pretty.
And there's videos of them trying to get
up and falling down and trying to get
up.
And you should see the kosher machines.
They do have kosher
machine as long as it's,
as long as it lasts,
as long as it's been blessed.
That gets approved for kosher,
but it's even worse because it's like,
like the cows go in and they just like
rip their throat out with like a raw and
it's,
it's one of the things
where people think that,
oh,
you know,
Dave is the opposite of Vegan.
I'm like,
no,
I care a lot about the quality of the
animals I eat and the quality of the food
I eat.
But I also care about the quality of
my life and wanting to do with it.
And if I'm slowing myself down
by eating inappropriate foods.
There's also another thing
we've got to talk about,
talking about animal suffering.
I'm in Tibet,
right?
I spend like a couple months,
actually three months walking around
Asia visiting monasteries and stuff and I
went to this monster.
I had the Vegan vegetarian diet for um,
she was Vegan for like 10 days.
I'm farting like a machine the whole time.
And then afterwards they go to another
monastery in Lhasa and there's this giant
Yak skin on the prayer pole in
the middle of the monastery.
And so I asked the head Lama Guy,
and I said,
okay,
like you're a hypocrite.
Like you'd say,
no killing,
and you've got a dead animal
hanging on your prayer pole,
like what's the deal?
And he just looked at me and he,
you know,
the way like Buddhist monks kind of do,
we just kind of laughed and he said,
oh,
one death feeds everyone.
And then you walked away.
Like that was his whole thing.
And I thought about that.
If I eat two pounds of grass
fed beef every day for a year,
I killed 0.7 animals in
the entire food chain.
If I'm Vegan and I eat soy nuggets,
every bowl of soy nuggets is killing
hundreds of animals because the tractor
goes through and cuts down the soil.
The soil,
not,
we're not even talking about
what it did to the soil microbes,
but it cuts down all the soil.
It chops up the bunnies and their
cute little faces and the turtles.
And the grasshoppers and the worms and
all the other stuff there and basically
you look at the number of animals
killed to bring you a bowl of grain.
It's way in excess of
what grass fed beef does.
The vegan argument is,
well there's enough grass fed
beef for everyone and I'm like,
yeah,
that's because people don't ask for it.
You asked for it.
We'll turn the golf courses into basically
grass fed beef manufacturing plants.
There's plenty of them
out there to do that.
By the way,
like there's people who've done the math.
It would be a B,
it would be a smaller cow.
You wouldn't have nearly as much
fat and the taste is different.
The taste is different and this is
Rogan doesn't like the grass fed beef.
I try to cook the grass fit man.
Taste tea.
Can we just say this podcast is grass
fed now by how many grass fed is in it?
Yeah,
it just matters.
It's stamped.
I would eat a bowl of gravel if,
if I could perform.
I want it like I have
real dogma about this.
Like,
I don't,
I don't care like food.
For me it's like optimal
fuel for human potential.
That's it.
Not just delicious as well.
I mean,
I love the deliciousness.
I have a cookbook out for God's sake.
Oh deal.
It's called the upgraded chef.
It's like how do you cook stuff fast
to produce the least toxins that you
perform better on it.
This is so fast.
And it was this a long journey for you?
Yeah,
for 15 years.
I mean I spend a quarter million dollars
upgrading myself and I started like
tracking how I felt and how
I was performing and was I
gaining weight or losing
weight and did my joints
hurt and all this stuff.
And I came to this conclusion that you
can't change one variable and expect
something to work.
You've got to change a lot of variables
at once and then start adding things
back in.
Because let's say you're allergic
to just like milk and wheat,
which so many people are,
oh this week I'll no wheat,
nothing changed this
week I'll eat no dairy,
nothing changed.
So you assume nothing happened.
The problem is there's many things
that cause inflammation at its core.
The bulletproof diet is
about reducing inflammation.
And here's the secret.
When you look at a food,
there's three ways of looking at it.
The first one is does it have
the right macronutrients?
So like if I needed to eat some
protein or I need to eat some,
some fat,
is it in there?
But here's the funny thing,
people don't think about it so much.
You know,
if we said,
look,
you need to get 200
grams of protein today,
we generally say,
yeah,
that's good,
but wait a minute.
Okay,
this little vial of protein is the act
of protein that's in black widow spider
venom.
And this is an egg,
okay?
How many grams of protein
you want to eat today?
Okay?
The bottom line is different proteins
do different things to your body.
So you've got to pick the
right protein in there.
And then the fats.
Do you want hydrogenated vegetable
oil or do you want coconut oil?
They're totally different on
what they do to your body.
So first you got to get those sorted out.
And then the second way you look at
your food is something called anti
nutrients.
And this is something that that most
modern nutritionist just don't pay
attention to.
Paleo people know about
some but not others.
And what's going on there is food
has a defense mechanism built in.
If you're a grain,
your job was to reproduce and that means
you coat yourself in pesticide to keep
the bugs from eating your
so you can reproduce.
It's natural pesticide is
called [inaudible] acid and
it inhibits whatever eats
you and inhibits their ability to
absorb minerals from their food.
So now what would I do
when I look at food?
Does it have the right macronutrients?
Doesn't have poison in it?
If so,
then I don't want to eat it.
And finally,
does it have a lot of other stuff like
B vitamins and minerals and the other
micronutrients you had
guys like this Andy Guy,
that aggregate nutrient index
guy at whole foods Ferman,
who by the way thinks Kales,
you know,
basically next to god he puts liver
like at a very low number on there.
Yet liver has a lot more
nutrients in it than Kale does.
The problem is he decided to divide
by calories for reasons I don't quite
understand what's going on.
There is a focus on micronutrients,
ignoring anti nutrients and ignoring
the function of food is fuel and they're
also doing that because they have
a pro animal sort of an agenda.
Oh yeah.
There's definitely agenda behind that.
There's a lot of people,
like I've had conversations
with people who are vegans
and they will tell you that it's only
for health purposes and then I bring up
fish oil and most of them,
they don't take fish oil and I say,
well,
why?
If it's just for health reasons,
fish oil has been shown to be very,
very beneficial,
but it gets squirrely.
They start talking about
eating flax seeds and shit.
You know if you're
going to eat flax seeds,
flax seed oil oxidizes
the second at Cs air,
like it's an incredibly unstable,
even in Ayurvedic Medicine,
they tell you,
you know flaxseed oil is a drying oil
and your body can convert that to the
healthy Omega threes out a ratio of 40
to one you'll be 40 grams of flax oil.
You get one gram of the good stuff and
you've got to dispose of the other 39
grams that cause inflammation in the body.
Whoa.
Yeah.
That's why I don't recommend
flips on its between fish oil.
It actually counteracts that
and the fights inflammation,
which is why it's so great for grapplers.
Oh,
it's huge.
Yeah.
Guys are always in a lot of guys who are
into crossfit as well and heavy doses
of fish oil.
Yeah.
It's an anti inflammatory,
right?
It's good stuff,
but I tell you,
if you use Krill,
it's going to work better because
Krill has the same EPA and Dha,
but its phosphorolated.
It's bound to phospholipids,
which means that your
brain can use it directly.
Fish oil.
It's gotta be phosphorolated and he's you.
You need to get extra phosphate.
I was searing,
I'm calling to do that in your diet.
So you have to take Coleen supplements.
If you take fish oil to get the October,
maybe just eat eggs except Coleen.
Yeah,
because here's the thing,
some of the like super
strong coding supplements,
like if there's no question they have
a really beneficial effect in like most
people in some people too much.
Coleen has like a reverse effect and it's
probably like maybe a third of people.
So it is one of those things
where if you get it in your food,
you're good.
And if the calling supplements
make you feel really good,
which they do for the
vast majority people,
like I'm a fan of Coleen
supplements in general,
I recommend them on the blog.
Like you've got that ingredient
in Alpha Beta and Alpha brain.
And like,
by the way,
that's just a killer list
of nootropic ingredients.
I,
I fully,
fully approved that bulletproof
level supplement for sure.
Awesome.
Thank you.
And uh,
the,
the thing is though,
if you're one of those
Coleen sensitive people,
you might not want a ton of Coleen.
Like you want to limit
yourself to a certain amount.
We've had issues with that with
people getting really sensitive,
like draw attention and headaches.
Yeah,
yeah.
And those are the people
who are calling dominant.
But here's the kicker.
You get those people to take antiacid Tam,
like the stuff I've got in my site
and our acid tam uses up extra Coleen.
So that's an interesting
way of using a smart drug.
And this is actually a drug,
not a,
not a natural substance,
but it's one that I'll bring
your colon levels down,
which means you can benefit
from the other stuff that's in,
um,
Alpha brain.
But you also get this boost from
the other type of nootropic.
How many different
things do you take a day?
Uh,
I take probably on an
average day about 40 pills.
See,
I told you I'm not crazy.
I know.
Here's,
here's a crazy number.
When I was really focused on like,
like getting my health all the way where
I wanted it before I was all the way.
Where am I did a 187 pills
a day for several months.
Now.
What about the actual capsule itself?
What are those made out of gelatin?
Is that no big deal for your body,
the process you actually need gelatin
our diets or gelatin deficient right now.
Oh really?
Yeah.
And you know,
we eat all the muscles in the animal,
but in the old days or mom would boil
the chicken and eat all the cartilage and
all that.
So I actually carry gelatin and Collagen
on the site because when people eat
that stuff,
their joints get healthier.
And there's another thing and this whole
electrical part of the body is not well
known,
but you know all those acupuncture
Meridian points and things like that.
Well,
electricity flows through your skin,
not just in your nerves and you need
collagen in your skin in order to,
to bring the water into the skin so
you can carry electricity efficiently.
So when you eat enough collagen
in the form of gelatin,
knocks blocks,
whatever,
I have grass fed gelatin that I use.
Whoa.
But you do that.
You actually,
you functioned better on many levels,
including on the inflammation level.
A lot of fighters are
starting to take Jello.
And I noticed it in,
they did this,
I'm like sort of cribs
thing with Minotauro.
Nogueira go.
Just fought a recently in UFC this past
weekend and they went to his house.
He had a stack of Jello,
said he had,
this is make me feel good.
I mean it works even for sleep.
Sometimes it helps.
Hello?
I did not know.
The problem is like,
I mean industrial Jellos disgusting.
Like giving,
you want to know what's in there,
what is in there.
Like they,
they're taking a hooves and like
snouts and like all these like office,
it's like the Bologna of protein powder.
It's not good.
Well,
I mean it,
it's better than no Collagen.
What's most,
what's the best made that the best is
made out of the skin of the animal.
The skin.
Yeah.
So like that's the sort of stuff that,
that I use typically.
Um,
in fact next week I'll have,
um,
I'll have of listing for the,
the best kind of of it I've been
exploring college and for years.
So you can take straight college and you
can take straight gelatin and it's just
a question of basically how you want
it to taste and how you want it to be
absorbed into your food.
But the old days we would
make like soup from bones.
It's too much work.
So what you do now as you take a couple
of scoops of collagen powder and you
just put it in your smoothie or putting
in your soup and you've got all the
benefits of bone broth
with none of the trouble.
It's just,
it's too much work to
make all that prof no,
there's just a process.
They just take the,
the leather,
they take the outside and turn it into,
take the outside and they expose it
to enzymes and a [inaudible] acid.
Yeah.
And that breaks it down and
it's kind of a useful food.
It's one of those things that we used
to fight for a hundred years ago because
you had to get enough of it.
And it was one of the ways
of using the whole animal.
And now we just toss it.
And mostly so in your opinion and with
all those things that you've researched,
what you found is that you can't even
just not even like eggs is not good
enough.
Fish is not good enough.
Like you need animals,
you need mammals,
you need,
you need cows and shit.
At least some of the time.
I absolutely believe that.
I also believe,
let's face it,
you kill a chicken,
did one meal to kill that animal.
And chickens have the worst lives ever
unless they're like super pastured,
crazy expensive chickens.
So like you want to be a tortured animal.
Modern chickens can't even stand up on
their own because their breasts are so
big.
Like,
like they're one of
the most tweak species.
Yeah.
They're pretty tweak.
It's pretty fucked up when you see one
of those gigantic chicken farms and
they're all stacked on top of each
other and it just crap on each other.
And also,
so I see these people,
I could never eat red meat.
I'm like,
dude,
one animal will feed two
people basically for two years.
If they're eating normal amounts of it,
that's less death.
Yeah.
But it's a big death.
It's like nobody has a
problem with killing ants.
People are not like making protests in
front of a stores that sell raid ant
killer.
They don't give a fuck about the
hands cause they're so small.
It's like we have like a thing that you
could take an aunt like you find any on
any accountant gets dual your finger
and do that and you just flick it on the
ground like you went away.
You can't do that to a rat.
You can't hit a rat with a hammer and
it just throw it on the floor and now
you've got to clean that thing up.
The snail,
remember when it made that snail video
and everyone got pissed off at me?
Yeah.
He can't kill snails.
Snails big enough.
He stomped on an ant.
No one would have given a shit.
But you killed a snail?
No,
like this son of a bitch.
I put a snail on a list of
marines strip and it was awesome.
The thing about the thing about cows,
by the way,
he's almost 40 the,
the thing about cows,
those that they're big and like a,
you know,
an ant's tiny and it doesn't really bug
us that you can buy poisoned for ants
anywhere.
If you could sell cowboys and at the
store people would freak out because you
can't just kill cows like that.
They,
you know that you can buy rat poison.
Yeah.
The clients care about rats,
but then there's people
who have rats for pets.
Like man,
there's a lot of people that
actually lived off rats and the,
and what was it?
I forget Peru.
I believe we're Guinea pigs.
I like super common.
I've eaten a Guinea pig.
What is it like in Peru?
Yeah,
I went down there to do Iowasca with a
showman and they have Guinea pig food.
Yeah,
it's native.
There they are.
Let me see the technical term for it.
Fucking disgusting.
There's like no meat on them and they
stopped them with Rick rice and vegetables
don't taste good.
That's the,
there's like five bites of meat on a
whole Guinea pig and it doesn't taste very
good.
The bites you can get and the rest
of it's just like bones and skin.
It was the little family gross.
Those people are just trying to get by.
Yeah,
that's some tough times.
What I saw was this,
um,
Anthony Bourdain show and they went over
this guy's house and they had Guinea
pigs running around the kitchen,
like constantly running.
They were everywhere and
they would just pick one up,
take them over,
snap kill him,
got em and start cooking it.
And all these other dump
Fox are just running around.
They're like their pets.
It's practically until they get killed.
But they have a concert,
you say it's awful,
but they have a constant supply of meat.
And your point of view from Burbank,
you know,
is very different than their
point of view living in Peru.
There are two adorable though.
I yeah,
these houses don't even have windows.
Dude.
I used to have them as pets.
They are kind of cute but I
got enough if I was hungry.
[inaudible] you have children
and your children are hungry,
you're gonna eat the fuck out of some
Guinea pigs and there they're everywhere.
Dude.
They have like 30 of them.
We had cat,
not on purpose but I've been to a
lot of Taco trucks so I'm not sure.
Well do you think taco trucks really,
so really depends on where you are.
And I have a theory,
tell me if this theory
makes any sense at all.
But I have a theory that things that are
difficult to catch or good for you like
wild fish,
wild game,
things that run quick like deer,
deer.
Very good for you because they run fast
to try and get the fuck away cause they
know that delicious.
They know there's what like highly
sought after and then things like cows,
it just kind of stand around.
Probably not as good as
anything to that theory.
I don't buy it either.
Here's why the thing humming dirt mark,
the things that can run really fast and
sprint don't have enough fat on them.
Like when the Indians
would kill a buffalo,
like the first thing you eat is like
the big fatty hump on the back and then
that's,
that's a fat solid fat.
Is that like for storing food for them?
So in fact if you take a real grasp
at buffalo that fat is orange.
It's actually like almost like a salmon
color and most of the buffalo you can
buy it,
they finish on grand cause no
one wants to buy orange fat.
I'm like man give me a big old like
two pound hunk of orange fat like that.
Why can they,
I mean the most of it finishes
on green or all of it come in,
can you get it?
It finishes on on,
I've asked that like butchers that
really high end markets about that and
they're like yeah we were one of the
guys said and we tried it one time at
orange,
we've got to throw it out.
No one would buy it.
That's so your probably order it online
just to get it like a hundred percent
grass fed.
I need to get that.
Just to find out what it would taste like.
It's pretty delicious when
you get like real fat.
In fact bisons good.
Even if you take like just the fats
and good quality butter versus uh,
you know,
crap butter.
I've had like vegetarian friends,
I'm like,
come on over,
let me make one of my soups for you.
And it's,
you know,
butter and I use the MCT oil.
In fact,
next week I've got my bulletproof MCT oil,
like,
like on the shelves.
I'm super stoked on that.
What is it?
It's a six times stronger
extract of coconut oil.
So it's two of the medium change.
The ones that are most responsible for
losing weight and for cognitive function
where that's all that's in
there and it has no flavor.
So you can like make Manet's out of it.
How's that created?
They take coconut oil and process
that somebody has centrifuged.
Yeah,
so we spin it and then we
pull out just those ones.
And I have the only brand I've,
I've heard anywhere.
What does that center future work?
So it's a,
basically you just spin it really fast
and when they do like your blood tubes to
separate out the plasma and the
and the cells when you spin it,
the different weights of fat line up.
So we pull out the two most precious
ones right in the middle band there and
then we take the rest of it and
we give that to other people.
It's ridiculous.
And this is coming out right now.
It's like it should be
on the site right now.
Like you can preorder it.
I just put it out the bulletproof
or bulletproof executive coms,
bulletproof exec.com bulletproof exact.com
and you have your whole story is up
there of how you,
so for Po folks that don't have the
patients to go and listen to this podcast
again,
there's a fuck load of information on
this site as well as not just the upgraded
MCT oil.
You've got upgraded coffee,
everything's upgraded,
great chef.
And here's what it means
when it's upgraded.
Like I'm looking at the whole process
of making something and how do you make
that process as good as it can be.
Like my background,
I really am a computer hacker.
Like I've studied computer science,
I work in computer security.
I'm not an actively a hacker,
like I'm an executive.
But like I understand the mindset of
changing a system to get the outcome you
want.
It turns out like to make the coffee.
The problem was actually how the
beans get turned into green coffee.
That's where most the problems happen.
So I went through,
I learned all about all this
stuff from multiple disciplines,
pulled it all together and said,
what if I created this new
process for making coffee?
They didn't have the toxins in it.
And you look at that like we're about
done with the study where we're getting
advice from Stanford University on
the cognitive function of this coffee.
So we're comparing normal coffee versus
this upgraded coffee to show what it
does to your response
time and your attention.
And like we don't have enough results to
be statistically significant yet we're
still recruiting people.
The results I have say yeah works.
So it's like this is real stuff.
And every step of the way when you create
a food tells you how the food is going
to make you perform.
And what I'm trying to do is help people
understand like if for one day they can
just have the best day ever where
like their energy and their focus and
everything is super clear and they
just like feel like a great golden God.
If you do that one time,
you know you're capable of it and
you can start working towards that.
But most people I know have felt like
crap without knowing it most of their
life.
They've never had a wonderful day.
Once you have that day you can learn
how to kick more ass repeatedly.
So it's like get all the crap out of that.
I just do it right for a week
and just see what can happen.
You look at the comments on my blog,
like people,
they do this,
it takes like six weeks.
It's not that hard to do and all of a
sudden like you know you have twice the
energy you had before.
Like that's what I'm
looking to do for people.
And when you have twice the energy,
you get twice the shit done.
I tell you,
I mentioned I'm a full time executive.
I wrote this book,
Wiley's my publisher Gary Tobbs
introduced me to my agent in New York.
Like it's a tier one book
with 1300 references.
I started the bulletproof executive blog,
which is in the top 25,000 blogs now,
150,000 people a month.
See yet.
Uh,
and I'm a dad of two young kids.
I see them on a very regular basis.
Like for me to be able
to do all this stuff,
I could have never done this in my mid
twenties it's cause I trained my brain
because I got my mitochondria functioning
and I got my hormones functioning.
You looked at the body
like your computer system.
Absolutely.
And where are you the
first kind of do that?
You know,
there's,
there aren't that many computer guys.
Like I'm 40 and the oldest
computer guys are like 65 right.
So certainly we've talked for
years about this and there's,
you know,
the whole cyber punk thing,
which I admit,
I admit I was a part of,
you know,
mirrored sunglasses and stuff like that.
But I'm one of the early guys like,
um,
a lot of the Russians,
the Russian space program
did a lot of this stuff.
Like this is a device,
this is called a is an older one,
but it's the only one
you can get that does,
that does programming where
you can pick the frequency.
But I'll run a current across my brain.
This is actively at the same
thing you do to a computer.
When you do that,
you can put yourself in the gamma state.
That's really hard to get into.
You just stick the electrodes on your
head and where that puts you in a gamma
state.
And what's the benefit of that?
Gamma state is actually a state where
the Dalai Lama just a announced a cash
reward for anyone who could help him
get into a gamma state in less than four
hours.
Cause that's how long it takes him.
He's looking for
neuroscience ways to do it.
So literally you stick these things
on your forehead as a Dalai Lama.
Try the isolation tanks.
I don't know,
but it wouldn't surprise me.
He's pretty open with his
neuro neuroscience stuff.
But you hook this thing up,
you turn it on like that
and now it's running.
You start good.
It sounds like you're,
it sounds like a
Frankenstein or something.
What are you doing?
So
it's grass fed.
What I'm doing now,
I'm running,
running my brain is crap.
Sematic and grass fed drink.
So what you do something like that.
It is literally like you watered,
changing the waves in your
brain like a computer.
And what is the benefit of that?
Again,
like when you put that on,
what is it actively do to you?
It depends on what setting you put it on.
If I'm going to be writing like a lot,
I'll put it on a gamma state and
you're just in this like focused,
amazing kind of flow state.
Although Alpha is also something
that's more recognized as a flow state,
so you can control what
state your brain is in.
You want to get like rapid
recovery during sleep.
If I'm only going to sleep two hours,
I put that on and I put it on 1.5 hertz,
which is associated with deep sleep.
And when I wake up I feel really good.
I didn't get all the benefits of
memory consolidation and dreaming.
Do you sell this thing?
No.
You can just buy it.
Do you explained it on
your website or anywhere?
Yeah,
I have a top 10 brain hacks.
Video is a talk.
I gave it south by southwest on this.
I would love to try that.
And so it's giving a low
level electrical signal.
Yup.
And what does it do exactly?
In fact,
I have a touching the head.
So it's sending electrical
waves in the brain.
It's running a slight
current back and forth.
I try that one again.
Yeah,
sure.
I've had,
I got one.
You got me one a while ago.
We were trying to get you to
quit smoking and didn't work.
You've never used it either?
No,
I used it a lot.
It's just,
it's shocked I stick those
things on your forehead.
Yeah.
I'd like clips to your ears,
right?
It was a little freaky.
Yeah,
this one you said of your clips,
but I used to,
yeah,
I use the temple things just
because they're a little easier.
Yeah.
And uh,
this is actually like
a 10 year old device.
The problem is most of the new ones have
only one frequency and this one lets
you adjust the frequencies,
which is,
which is helpful.
Okay.
I'm putting on my head and hit the power
button on there or just hand me the
controls if you want it.
Okay.
How are you up?
Stay posted later.
Alright.
That feels weird.
There's a volume control right here.
It's Ding in my head.
It feels like there's up turn up,
turn that volume control
until it doesn't stain.
It feels like a bee who's like trying
to like say he's playing a game of just
the tip.
There you go.
These playing just the tip of the
Stinger is not quite seem like,
come on man.
Just let me get the Zyban.
Yeah.
Um,
just,
it feels interesting.
Turn.
Turn it down so it doesn't hurt,
that's for sure.
What is it at now?
I turned it up.
Okay.
Is that bad?
It hurts.
No,
it's not bad,
but it'll still work if you just have
a little tiny tingle that you do.
You don't want to get really smart.
If I have to fucking suffer
through a little bit of pain,
I'm down to it.
If you do this for 1520 minutes
for the next several hours,
the Alpha and the front half of your
brain will be much higher than it was
before.
Why doesn't everybody know about this?
This is ridiculous.
Iphone could do this.
How serious.
It's not that hard.
This could be an APP.
It,
well,
I mean,
you'd have to set the
iPhone up to do that,
but this whole quantified self thing I
do like there's a whole bunch of people
looking at this stuff.
How long before the government
arrested you for all this?
You know,
I didn't create super people.
Well,
the only thing that I've invented that's,
that's like new.
Some of the training
techniques are different,
but like I didn't invent
cerebral electrical
stimulation the Russians
did in their space program.
The reason that this came about is they
said it costs a lot of money to send a
cosmonaut up into space.
What if we didn't have,
if they didn't sleep,
we could send one third
less cost the knots.
So they built this,
well I have a uh,
one of those turbo sonic machines.
I know that you've talked very highly of
those things to tell me what those do.
Cause somebody told me when
I bought it and I forgot,
but I use it all the time.
Oh yeah.
Awesome.
Those things rock.
So I'll tell you flat out,
you know,
if you can afford 12 or 15
grand by the turbo sonic,
I've used one for almost a year.
It's the most programmable
and it's the quietest,
but does the same thing
that these other ones do.
Any of the ones that vibrate you up and
down only are going to have the same
effect.
There's a whole bunch of cheap ones
that do like a side to side rocking that
messes up your low back.
So,
and also they tend to break.
I've broken welds on a
couple of the stoop units.
It's some sort of an soundwave
with speaker mechanism.
It's not really a sound
wave with turbo sonic,
but it is a speaker mechanism.
You've seen like a Woofer,
like a heavy duty
subwoofer and it goes doon,
doon,
doon.
What's going on there is they
took the sound baffles off,
but they left us those speaker coil.
So it moves you up using that really
efficient way of moving that speaker uses.
It's very precise.
I'm the one that I have that costs 10%
as much to make it like within reach for
the normal person.
It uses a motor,
so it's louder,
but it has exactly the same up and down
vibration that the turbo sonic would
have.
And there's another brand called power
played out there and they're all based on
very similar principles and that's that
when you vibrate the body like that,
you're triggering something called
PSO electric signals in the bone.
So it increases bone density.
Your muscles have to keep
tensing and releasing,
tensing and releasing.
So you actually can build muscle on those,
especially if you know
you hold a kettle bell.
Um,
you know,
just hold out like this.
Like all of a sudden,
30 times a second.
You know,
you're doing this,
and I hate to say this is like the
adult version of the shake weight,
but it's powered and it seriously works
in the final thing you get from this has
to do with uh,
lymphatic circulation in the body.
So we have this whole waste,
the waste elimination system
called your lymph system.
And the way the lymph moves
is you have to move your body.
And this is why people say,
Oh,
you have to move.
Movement is so important for you move.
It's important because it moves lymph.
It's not cause it burns calories,
it doesn't burn calories.
That's a distraction.
Movement doesn't burn calories
when it burns calories,
but that doesn't make you lose weight.
Like compared to say,
a short high intensity interval will make
you lose more weight than going for a
walk that burns more calories in the end.
The high intensity interval,
it's a hormonal effect you're getting.
This is like Dr Doug Mic,
uh,
macduffs work.
Uh,
so I met gfes work,
um,
from body by science.
Like there's definitely like enormous
loads of research there about caloric
consumption from exercise and diet and
they don't line up for weight loss.
They just,
in fact,
yeah,
I have a really good blog post about that.
Whoa.
In fact,
the blog post is called,
it's not the calories stupid and it was
in response to a New York Times piece
where they actually wrote
it's the calorie stupid.
Even though the study that they'd written
about showed it wasn't the calories
like different people at the same amount
of calories and gain different amounts
of fat.
Like how did that happen?
But
uh,
on the vibration plate,
you're of course you're,
you're burning energy but you're moving
all the lymphatic fluids in the body and
your micro capillaries are getting
stimulated to like parts of you get shaken
that might not normally get circulation.
So you typically feel like a burst of
energy when you're done with it and you,
you tend to slim down.
Like I noticed like especially if
you have inflammation going on,
I'm still,
because of my health background,
I still,
I get inflamed.
He's ate the wrong stuff.
I puff up,
you do that and it helps you
to dump the extra inflammation.
So it's amazing detox plus exercise plus
general stimulation of your body all at
once.
Like for 15 minutes a day.
It's,
it's a total bargain just
in terms of time spent,
whether it's on a turbo sonic
or or the bulletproof vibe,
they,
they both achieve the same kind of goals,
but I'll tell you flat out you've got
the Cadillac or the Mercedes of them,
the turbo sonic to the best made anywhere.
Yeah,
I do 10 minutes of it before a workout.
Yeah.
I'll do a 10 minute like shakedown.
Like you really look at it.
It feels good,
doesn't it?
It feels amazing.
I love that feeling.
It's amazing.
And then when it really,
what's really going fast for folks
who've never tried it before,
if you,
if you're anywhere near Venice,
whoops,
I lost one of my fucking Frankenstein.
No lobes.
If you're anywhere near Venice,
the float lab has it.
Crash is the one who sold me mine.
He's the fucking mad scientists,
ladies and gentlemen to
given me an updated tank.
Ladies and gentleman,
there's a new tank.
Did crash is created.
It's even though he's a mad scientist,
he's a crazy man,
but he uh,
he runs the float lab,
the best isolation tanks
bar none in the world.
I might get one.
I'm,
I'm looking at one.
How the fuck do you not have one?
I've been looking at building one,
but because I moved up to BC a couple
of years ago and look at it by a ranch.
So as soon as I get the ranch,
I'm getting a good tank,
but I don't want to move it into
the place where I'm living now.
You should have it right in this crash.
We'll set it up and do everything for you.
You should have one right now.
Especially you.
How many times have you used,
well,
I've used the float tank once,
like 10 years ago.
Dare you sir?
Hooking up these fucking
electrodes to your brain.
You're not even taking advantage
of one of the craziest pieces of,
Oh,
I have machine I love.
So I love it.
It's a huge thing.
You only did it once.
I only did it once.
It's a question of where you live,
right?
If there's not a float tank area and yeah,
it,
it's on my list.
Not for me it wasn't.
I did it once and I was looking to buy
a house and one of the prerequisites for
buying the house was
having a room for the tank.
My,
the House I'm looking to buy right now,
same thing.
It's got to have space.
I have to have space for a pool table.
I have to have space for the
tank that's non negotiable.
Everything else I can
lift weights at the gym,
but they need a tank in the house.
It's hard to find a tank,
you know,
if you don't live near Venice.
The tank for me is something that anyone
who's thinking about improving must
have for creativity.
It is.
It's a fascinating tool,
self introspective thinking and you know,
it's just,
it's amazing.
In fact,
it's one of those technologies and there's
a whole bunch of them out there that
allows the prefrontal Cortex,
like the human part of your brain that
you think of as you to become aware of
that,
that really fast reptilian brain that
runs circles around you like you.
You can't even see it happening
until you get rid of all the noise.
And when you get into that flow tank all
of a sudden like you do that personal
exploration,
you can,
you can do amazing
things there.
You can do amazing things and you learn
amazing things out about yourself.
You start making these
drastic improvements in the
way you look at things in
there.
Cause it's so self analytical.
It's so,
it's so a self observational.
Then when you're in there you just,
you're not,
you don't have anything
going on with your body.
So you're just alone with your
thoughts and you have to address them.
You can't get confused and
separated with busy work.
You just,
you're,
you're not going to within 20 minutes
anything that's really fucking with you.
We'll come to the surface.
Have you ever played with neurofeedback?
What does that,
this is when you hook electrodes up to
your head and you get the signal from
your brain,
oh,
this is profound stuff.
It,
it's on par with a float tank.
In fact,
I've had my own EEG since 1998.
Whoa.
Um,
be like at home because it's that
impactful and what you do there is,
is your brain,
it's unable to see itself.
Like your brand can see
the whole world around you,
but it doesn't have nerves inside itself.
That's why I like you see brand surgery,
they can take the top off your head and
like poke at your brain and it doesn't
hurt.
There's no nerves in there.
There's nurses in your arm,
like you cut your arm.
Then what's going to happen is,
well,
there's nerves there and in the
arm heals relatively quickly.
We get these traumatic brain injuries.
They don't heal very well because the
brain doesn't even know what's broken.
So it's incredibly good at the world,
incredibly bad at itself.
So what you do is you get
the signal from the brain,
you'd play it through an amplifier,
it turns it into music and it
plays the music back to you.
And when you think about something
in the music gets louder.
When you think about something else,
music gets quieter.
So you can teach the brain
to think in a new way.
So I've done an extensive neurofeedback
training and literally seven days was
the equivalent of 40 years
of daily zen practice.
This was really,
really hardcore intense seven days.
It was like a hardest
thing I've ever done.
It cost me 20 grand and I was hooked up
to it like an $11 million EEG machine
for at least half that time.
But I mean you want to
introspection when you look at a,
when you hear a sound,
your brain can't help but optimize itself.
Like it tells you when
you're doing it wrong.
You think of like the meditation
path that people are on there.
Like,
oh,
I meditate this way.
Oh I did it wrong for five years,
sorry.
And then they do it over here
and they sort of meander.
And then you know their
teachers tell them,
try meditating this way.
Well what if there was a
computer and it lit up the path.
So like on either side of the path there's
like letting you know the sounds get
quiet and either side of the path.
All of a sudden you can do meditative
type of things to yourself that would take
you years of focused practice.
You can do it in days and because
synaptogenesis this part of the brain that
makes new synapses happens
within like 20 days.
You can totally rewire your head in short,
short amounts of time,
like unbelievably short.
So you rewire your head by
use of electrical frequencies
so you can literally
program it to do exactly
what you wanted to do.
Right?
But we're not putting the
frequencies into the head.
All we're doing is we're using like a
mirror because the brain doesn't have any
nerves inside itself.
The brain will on its own figure out,
oh my God,
that sound,
that's me.
And it'll start doing things
to like adjust how it works.
It's like for things like add people
who have like been hit on the head,
these guys,
they,
they get improved very dramatically.
But the kind I did is
correlated with a 12 IQ point,
boost that stable year later
and like 50% more creativity.
Wow.
Amazing.
Wait a minute.
What do we have to do?
How do I get it on this?
Um,
well I will,
uh,
I'll hook you up with a guy who does it.
He runs a private facility.
How much time?
It takes seven full days and takes
15 grand plus travel expenses.
Sounds like I'm getting robbed.
It's,
is it behind a seven 11 nonsense.
The Guy,
the guys in
ex,
uh,
he's an ex faculty member from UCS staff.
Yeah.
He's been doing this for 35 years
and then runs a private facility.
By the way,
you're getting robbed.
This should be available on every street
corner and it should be in every school
and it should cost about 300 bucks.
It would transform society.
The fact that it's 15 grand
pisses me off everyday,
which is why I'm not telling you his
name right now because shut this website
down anyway.
But yeah,
we will crush you a websites on that
sounds like really for seven days though.
It actually doesn't sound like a rip
off if it turns into a super genius.
It sounds like it was.
I mean I,
I'd already done a lot of work on myself,
but I came out of there and like
the voice in your head that,
that thing that gets in your way,
like it's your bitch when you're done.
Like that's so you can go there and it
just completely rewires your brain in
seven days.
It is hard work.
Don't get me wrong.
You have to do what is the hardware.
You sit there in a dark room with a
speaker on either side of your head and
eight electrodes glued to
your head and then you,
you do whatever you have to do to make
the sound louder and make your score go
higher.
And the first three days you just
like your brain just doing his thing.
And then after that you have
to dig in on like you're,
you're most like,
it's just like in a float tank.
My ultimate fantasy,
it would be that I'd go there and I'm
like a super gifted at this and I break
the whole,
we're getting,
we're getting to that point.
So we didn't do this.
I want you to do this.
I think it's not going to judge all.
I'll do it with you.
I've actually been
thinking about going back.
Can you lay on top of each other women?
Can you get the super would if she would
like a fucking intellectual vampire now
get dumber and you get smarter.
Um,
what if he hacks?
That's what he's trying to do.
I'd like to remind you,
you've gotten my electrodes
on your forehead right now.
It's already been done
to bill this shit,
son.
You got to meet some little
stronger for this fat head.
What is this thing?
I think I saw it on your Twitter
about you paying to get hacked.
What was that all about?
Paying for what?
Maybe it,
hold on.
Nevermind
mean biohacking.
How much you spent biohack
the quarter million dollars.
Yeah.
Okay.
So over the past 15 years,
I've spent a quarter million dollars on
everything I can think of that improves
human performance.
I'm like,
I'm just going to do it.
So,
um,
20 grand.
Actually I did it a couple times.
So 20 grand in 25 grand,
whatever there.
Um,
I've taken ungodly numbers of
supplements and smart drugs.
I've tried all kinds of electronics.
I have like a whole mad
biohacker laboratory at home.
Like I've gotten my vibrating plate.
I've got an ozone generator.
I've got a couple different EEG machine
zone generator in my tank set up because
of crashed uses.
Purify the water.
That's the best way to purify water.
Powerful crush.
Are you,
are you sponsored by grass to pay for
all this Scott Industries or something?
Actually BC bud.
That's fine.
Have you ever looked into eating cannabis?
Um,
as a,
as a food?
Yeah.
Um,
I've looked at eating hemp,
not,
you mean you didn't have actual cannabis?
Cannabis is when you don't cook it.
It's not psychoactive.
Eat it.
The psychoactive plants of cannabis.
If you eat it does not make you high.
It just just by,
but it's incredibly healthy.
Oh,
interesting.
Beneficial.
Yeah.
And that's supposed to,
I've never tried it but
it sounds kind of cool.
It's supposed to be really great
to juice as well and interesting.
That's really cool.
Well,
if it was legal,
it'd be so easy and cheap to grow that
you could literally eat it that way for
health,
smoke it,
do whatever you want.
You wouldn't be such a,
the reason why it's such a
commodity is because it's illegal.
It's ridiculous.
You could throw seeds out the window
mean it's famous people who have been
driving their car,
they throw joints out the window,
they drive by six months later as a
fucking giant push of marijuana growing
there.
I mean it really is a
super hardy plant and,
and like the protein in
there is really high in Igg.
It's great protein.
It's a bit high in Omega six fats.
Um,
if it's all you're going to eat,
but certainly some of it,
it's fine.
But,
but if you get those protein,
it's one of effect.
I would say it's the best plant
source protein that I know of.
Yeah.
You can need a plan.
Sorry.
It's very digestible to,
that's my favorite part of it is that
it's the one of the few things hemp with
coconut juice and coconut oil,
but uh,
I use it with a c two oh baby see two oh
coconut juice because it is my favorite
if I can get raw.
Raw is Roz,
awesome.
Ross,
tough to fuck with if you can get robbed
but it only lasts for like a little
while.
It's the best.
You can't really keep it
in the fridge like you can,
but that damn stuff and force
protein part of the stuff that I use.
Yeah,
you could,
you could take it and go to the gym and
hour later it's the only thing that I
could do Jujitsu and an hour later
because it's so easy for your body digest.
It's just not taxing at all.
The stuff we use.
Two is the most expensive because it has
the highest ratio of protein to like to
like some of our more course
of the hearts are more course.
They don't have as high a ratio.
That's what you want to do.
Yeah.
It's uh,
it's really super easily digestible but
illegal to grow but not illegal to have
or sal,
so like,
like legal.
Thank you Canada,
the United States for fucking saying
that it's illegal to grow a plant.
Dunces it's just such,
you know,
we add on it.
We could have had a farm we were
thinking about like Vermont,
we looked into Vermont
because Vermont passed laws,
but the federal government
is clearly said,
we will lock you in jail if
you try to grow this plant.
Here's,
here's how to get past all of this.
I just figured it out.
Oh,
Monsanto needs to make
genetically modified pot and
then it'll be legal to grow
everywhere.
Listen.
Yeah.
But then they'll probably fuck with
a pot and the pot transmit Nazi,
turn you into an octopus or something.
Yeah.
It's going to do something to you.
It's going to ruin you.
I hope they don't do that and
case anyone there's listening.
Yeah,
please.
Monsanto leave.
We'd alone concentrate on sweet potatoes
or whatever the fuck you're doing.
It's this scary ass company,
man.
Somebody needs to get those
people some mushrooms.
Amen.
Get those people some mushrooms and
understand the impact of your decisions.
Just to put ones and Zeros.
There's some serious therapeutic
value to medicinal mushrooms.
Oh fuck yeah.
That's John Hopkins University showed
significant improvements in people's
personalities years later.
How many,
how many kilobytes is Joe's
brain being downloaded like,
like that's like a 32 megabyte
file are pretty smart right now.
Brian,
I know he's,
he's taking,
he just copied and pasted parents.
Yeah.
I don't even know what my own memories
or I'm actually on my iPad here.
I'm looking at what he's
thinking about and I feel dirty,
dirty,
not black hawks.
And that's your,
that's a flashback.
Flashback to the past sun.
How dare you.
Are you feeling anything
from the electrodes?
Um,
I don't know.
You know,
it's hard to say and I'll feel bad.
It gives me a pretty subtle and just,
you know,
see if you're in the zone one more
for the next few hours after this.
Yeah,
I think it's,
it feels cool.
I like it.
I liked the fact that I think
it does something for me.
But this other thing just
fucking seven day jammy.
That sounds,
uh,
how many hours a day?
Pretty much.
Most of them,
like,
like you,
when you get there,
you check in your watch and your cell
phone and you just like do it until you're
done.
You don't even pay attention to the time.
Like it's just like time goes away.
And all your folks who have done this,
10,000,
10,000 people have done this and
they've all reported similar results.
Army special forces had this sky
train them for seven months straight.
So it's like a Jason Bourne type thing.
Really.
So there's a way you can go and you sit
down in this fucking place for seven
days and this is a permanent change
in your Iq and your creativity.
Yup.
That's started kickstarted for you,
Joe.
We're going to make a movie about this
bitch.
I don't need,
I don't need that man.
I'm telling you,
man,
it for you.
You're talking about like,
you know,
add,
uh,
you know,
just like kind of have in your brain,
that's a comedian.
Brands all over the place.
You don't lose any of that creativity,
but it becomes malleable for you.
And like my,
my performance,
I did this in like 2008 or 2007,
I think.
2000.
No.
Anyway,
mid two thousands.
Um,
and I dunno,
like I came back,
I drive fast.
I've always driven fast.
I'm a very safe driver,
but when someone in a Prius cuts me off,
it pisses me off.
Right?
And it's always the
priestesses of cut you off.
So you know,
like you son of a bitch and
when I've dealt with this,
I came back,
I'm like,
oh,
it's one of the priests cut me off,
but zero emotional like costs.
All the energy that I used to waste on,
like getting pissed off about stuff that
didn't matter completely went back to
productivity and like
just kicking more ass.
It's amazing what happens when you just
teach your brain that you're the boss
and you tell you the little reptile brain
and they're just shut the hell up and
to do its job to keep you from burning
yourself to death or falling off a cliff,
but to not be freaking out the
rest of the time for no reason.
Is it possible to do that without
sitting in a room for seven days?
Get blasted with sounds.
You can do.
Give me some sound.
Alright,
give me,
give me a feel like a simulation.
Yeah.
What you think this could be black.
There you go.
Something like that.
It's kind of like that and then
you try and make it louder.